This message comes from Greenlight. Ready to start talking to your kids about financial literacy? Meet Greenlight, the debit card and money app that teaches kids and teens how to earn, save, spend wisely, and invest with your guardrails in place. With Greenlight, you can send money to kids instantly, set up chores, automate allowance, and keep an eye on your kids' spending with real-time notifications. Join millions of parents and kids building healthy financial habits together on Greenlight.
本消息来自Greenlight。准备好开始和孩子谈论金融知识了吗？认识一下Greenlight，这是一款借记卡和理财应用程序，它能在您设置的监管范围内，教导孩子和青少年如何赚钱、储蓄、明智消费以及投资。通过Greenlight，您可以即时给孩子转账、安排家务、自动发放零花钱，并通过实时通知随时关注孩子的消费情况。加入数百万家长的行列，与孩子一起在Greenlight上培养健康的理财习惯。
Sign up for Greenlight today at Greenlight.com slash Odyssey. This episode is brought to you by Missouri. From November 25th to December 2nd, get 25% off everything on orders over $150 in Missouri's biggest sale ever. From bold hoops to minimalist stacks, Missouri has something for everyone. Missouri makes handcrafted fine jewelry for every day made with responsibly sourced materials so you can look and feel good about gifting and wearing them. Shop your wishlist 25% off at majori.com today. Welcome to Second Drink the Alliance. Jenna, I feel like we need a cat calendar
今天就访问Greenlight.com/Odyssey注册Greenlight。本集由Missouri赞助。从11月25日到12月2日，在Missouri有史以来最大的促销活动中，订单满150美元即可享受全场75折优惠。从大胆的圆环耳饰到极简的叠戴款式，Missouri能满足每个人的需求。Missouri为日常佩戴制作手工精美首饰，采用负责任的材料，让您在赠送和佩戴时都能感到舒心。今天就访问majori.com，以75折优惠购买您的心愿单商品。欢迎来到《Second Drink the Alliance》。Jenna，我觉得我们需要一个猫咪日历
at front reception update. Well, they really made me wait for it this week. It's there, but you don't see it till 12 minutes and 50 seconds. 12 minutes? Cat calendar at reception. Yeah, yeah. Same calendar. Same cat, by the way.
在前台更新。好吧，他们这周确实让我等了很久。它在那儿，但直到12分50秒你才能看到它。12分钟？前台的猫咪日历。对，对。顺便说一下，还是同一个日历，同一只猫。
The month has not changed. No flips. Nope. There is also next to the cat calendar a giant poster that says all hands meeting on Saturday from 9 a.m. to noon. It's been there for weeks. What are we meeting about? I don't know and are we meeting every Saturday? It doesn't specify. And spoiler alert, I checked ahead both the cat calendar and the all-hands meeting
月份没有变。没有翻页。没有。在猫咪日历旁边还有一个巨大的海报，上面写着周六上午9点到中午举行全体员工会议。它已经在那里挂了好几周了。我们开会是为了什么？我不知道，而且我们每个周六都要开会吗？上面没写。而且剧透预警，我提前检查过了，猫咪日历和全体员工会议
are there through the end of season one. Noted. All right. Well, we'll have to see if they're in season two. You know I'll look for it. Well, I found a fun Michael Talkinghead that was in the table read draft for this episode. It reveals Michael's philosophy about sales and worker morale, how they're connected, and you know what? It sets up the whole birthday storyline,
一直持续到第一季结束。记下了。好吧，我们得看看第二季里还有没有。你知道我会去看的。嗯，我发现了一个有趣的Michael独白，在这一集的剧本初稿里。它揭示了Michael关于销售和员工士气的哲学，以及它们是如何联系在一起的，你知道吗？它为整个生日剧情线做了铺垫，
and I wanted to read it to you. Oh, okay. Michael looks at camera and says, "'All salesmen are selling one thing, happiness, "'and ourselves.' "'Look at TV ads now. "'A guy in a tuxedo breakdancing in a park, "'and four hot girls jumping in a puddle.
我想读给你听。哦，好的。Michael看着镜头说：“所有的推销员都在卖一样东西，幸福，还有我们自己。”“看看现在的电视广告。”“一个穿燕尾服的家伙在公园里跳霹雳舞，”“还有四个辣妹在水坑里跳来跳去。”
And what are they selling? I don't know. Could be coffee, could be typewriters. It's a lifestyle. The happiness lifestyle. But here's the catch. You wanna sell happy? You gots to be happy.
他们在卖什么？我不知道。可能是咖啡，可能是打字机。这是一种生活方式。幸福的生活方式。但关键在于。你想卖幸福？你得自己先幸福。
The problem I'm facing is there's a lot of rumors going through the office about downsizing. Everyone is worried about losing their job. It's brought our happiness level to down to here. The bomb falling whistle was in the script. That's why I did it. Just looking at me like, what are you doing? It was said to do that.
我面临的问题是办公室里流传着很多关于裁员的谣言。每个人都担心失去工作。这把我们的幸福指数降到了这里。剧本里有炸弹落下的哨声。所以我才做了那个动作。只是看着我，好像在说，你在干什么？剧本里就是这么写的。
It's brought it down to here. Not good. Time to call in a specialist. Professor me. And then the scene would have continued with Michael and Pam in his office, where he says that they need to boost morale by hosting a birthday party. Wow.
它把指数降到了这里。不好。是时候请专家了。教授我。然后这一幕本应继续，Michael和Pam在他的办公室里，他说他们需要通过举办生日派对来提振士气。哇。
I love so much when he's like, what are they selling? I don't know. Could be coffee, could be typewriters. And there's one other thing. You know Jenna, in this breakdown of this episode you mentioned a deleted scene between Michael and Pam where he is coaching her on how to answer the phones. Oh yes, I remember shooting it even now. Well it's really funny and you describe it so well but we didn't play the clip and I think we should hear it. I agree. Dunder Mifflin this is Pam. Hold please.
我太喜欢他说“他们在卖什么？我不知道。可能是咖啡，可能是打字机”的时候了。还有一件事。你知道吗Jenna，在这一集的解析中，你提到了Michael和Pam之间的一场被删减的戏，他正在指导她如何接听电话。哦，是的，即使现在我也记得拍摄那场戏的情景。嗯，它真的很有趣，你描述得也很好，但我们没有播放那个片段，我觉得我们应该听听。我同意。Dunder Mifflin，我是Pam。请稍等。
Eww. Eww. Rady then. Well I see you're going for the whole bored supermodel thing. Dunder Mifflin this is Pam. May I help you? Smoke, smoke, smoke, smoke. I wasn't really going for anything. I get it, I get it. A child is born. Beautiful sunset. Now I'll catch the next one. Unicorn walks into the office. Do you have an appointment? Look, Pam, this is not meant as a criticism, but let me tell you what you're doing wrong.
呃。呃。好吧。好吧，我看出你在走那种无聊超模的路线了。Dunder Mifflin，我是Pam。有什么可以帮您的吗？抽烟，抽烟，抽烟，抽烟。我其实没想走什么路线。我懂了，我懂了。一个孩子出生了。美丽的日落。现在我来接下一个。独角兽走进办公室。你有预约吗？听着，Pam，这并不是批评，但让我告诉你你哪里做错了。
You're the voice of this company, right? And when clients call and you're not smiling, they can hear that in your voice. It is a real turn-off. Are you being serious? Yes, I am, absolutely. So, the next call we get, I'd like you to smile. I'd like to see a big smile.
你是这家公司的代言人，对吧？当客户打电话来而你没有微笑时，他们能在你的声音里听出来。这真的很让人反感。你是认真的吗？是的，我是，绝对认真。所以，下一个电话打进来时，我希望你微笑。我想看到一个大大的微笑。
Okay. Okay. No one's calling. I know. Somebody will. And we'll wait. Sometimes there's a lot of time between the calls. I know. I know. We will wait.
好的。好的。没人打电话。我知道。会有人打的。我们会等。有时候电话之间会有很长的时间。我知道。我知道。我们会等。
Okay. We will wait for the calls. I knew, I knew, I knew. We will wait. Okay. We will wait for the call and you will smile. Let me try something just while we're waiting. Okay. Tell me if I'm smiling or not. Hi Pam, how are you? Was I smiling? Yes. Okay, let me try this one. Hi Pam, how are you? No. I mean you can tell. Yeah, I can tell. I was just smiling that time. And they can tell too. That was a good example.
好的。我们会等电话，你会微笑。趁我们等待的时候，让我试一下。好的。告诉我我是在微笑还是没在微笑。嗨Pam，你好吗？我刚才在微笑吗？是的。好的，让我试这个。嗨Pam，你好吗？没有。我是说你能看出来。是的，我能看出来。我刚才确实在微笑。他们也能看出来。那是个很好的例子。
Thank you. Alright, when we get a call I'll come back and you'll do the smile. Okay. It's shing time! It's shing time! Gunder Mifflin, this is Pam. One moment, I'll transfer you. Okay.
谢谢。好了，当有电话打进来时，我会回来，你就要微笑。好的。是时候闪亮登场了！是时候闪亮登场了！Dunder Mifflin，我是Pam。请稍等，我为您转接。好的。
So, lady, so much of that was improvisation. And I can remember when he says, it's okay, we'll wait. We were supposed to just sit there and like stare at each other. And they just kept the camera rolling. And that's why I said, sometimes there's a long time between calls. Cause you're like, what are we doing? Yes, and then Steve improvised that whole thing
所以，天哪，那里面有很多即兴发挥。我记得当他说“没关系，我们会等”的时候。我们本应该只是坐在那里，互相盯着看。他们就一直让摄像机开着。这就是为什么我说，有时候电话之间会有很长的时间。因为你会想，我们在干什么？是的，然后Steve即兴发挥了整段，
where he like puts his hands up in front of his face and he's like, am I smiling? Am I not smiling? And I was like, yes, no. And I'm like, that's a great example. You're so bored by him. We had so much fun. Well, you can actually watch that scene now
他把手放在脸前，说：“我在微笑吗？我没在微笑吗？”我就说，是的，没有。我说，那是个很好的例子。你被他弄得很无聊。我们玩得很开心。嗯，你现在其实可以看那场戏了，
because it's included in the super fan episodes. Well, one of the things I love about this episode of our podcast is that we got to hear from Phil Shea in this episode. And it just, I love that we have his voice on the podcast forever. I know. Me too. All right. Well, here's our breakdown of the Alliance. And this Wednesday on Office Ladies 6.0, we have an all new episode.
因为它被收录在超级粉丝剧集中了。嗯，关于我们播客的这一集，我喜欢的一点是我们听到了Phil Shea的声音。我真的很喜欢我们能永远在播客里保留他的声音。我知道。我也是。好了。好吧，这是我们对《The Alliance》的解析。本周三在《Office Ladies 6.0》上，我们有一集全新的节目。
We are kicking off the December holiday season with a request from our very own Cassie Jerkins. Yes, I can't believe I'm about to say this, but we are going to break down the Star Wars Christmas movie. Thank you, Cassie. Thank you. Now, Jenna, have you seen this? Nope. Not at the time we recorded this. It's really incredible. Like good? Incredible?
我们要以Cassie Jerkins的一个请求开启12月的假日季。是的，我不敢相信我要说这个，但我们要解析《星球大战》圣诞特辑。谢谢你，Cassie。谢谢。那么，Jenna，你看过这个吗？没有。在我们录制这一集的时候还没看。它真的很不可思议。是好的那种不可思议吗？
Yeah. Mm-hmm. Okay. I can't wait. That is on my docket between now and next Wednesday. Here is the Alliance. See you then. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
是的。嗯哼。好的。我等不及了。那就在下周三之前列入我的日程表了。这是《The Alliance》。到时候见。我是Jenna Fischer。我是Angela Kinsey。我们一起出演了《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hey, everyone.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。嘿，大家好。
It's Jenna Fisher. Hi, I'm Angela Kinsey. We have a great episode. It's The Alliance. It's so Fisher. Hi, I'm Angela Kinsey. We have a great episode, it's The Alliance. It's so good. I was tickled. Can I tell you, I was tickled watching this. Same.
我是Jenna Fisher。嗨，我是Angela Kinsey。我们有一集很棒的节目。是《The Alliance》。太Fisher了。嗨，我是Angela Kinsey。我们有一集很棒的节目，是《The Alliance》。太棒了。我被逗乐了。我能告诉你吗，看这一集我被逗乐了。我也是。
And I made my note cards, Jenna. I'm real excited about it. There are so many inside jokes from this episode for the office gang. We will get to that. Angela, I'm sorry, I think we have no time for chit chat this morning. What? We have no time, no, we have no time because this episode is too good.
我做了笔记卡，Jenna。我真的很兴奋。对于《办公室》的粉丝来说，这一集里有太多的内部梗了。我们会讲到的。Angela，抱歉，我觉得我们今天早上没时间闲聊了。什么？我们没时间，不，我们没时间，因为这一集太棒了。
There's too much to talk about. But Jenna, I love chit chat. I know. Well, you're going to have to save it. Well, I have really good day two hair for the ladies out there listening. I got a blow dry last night. This is what I said we don't have time for. This is literally what I just said.
有太多要聊的了。但是Jenna，我喜欢闲聊。我知道。好吧，你得留着以后聊。嗯，对于正在收听的女士们，我今天有很棒的“第二天发型”。我昨晚吹了头发。这就是我刚才说我们没时间聊的东西。这字面上就是我刚才说的。
I can't tell you how great my hair looks today and I didn't even brush it. I mean, the back of it's a hot mess. Let's, but you know, that's kind of my go-to. You are so proud of your hair that you had to get it in there even though I said we didn't have time. All right, Jenna, get to your dang fast facts. All right, The Alliance Season One, Episode Four.
我无法告诉你我今天的头发看起来有多棒，我甚至都没梳它。我是说，后面乱得一团糟。让我们，但你知道，那算是我的拿手好戏。你对你的头发如此自豪，以至于即使我说没时间，你也要把它塞进来。好了，Jenna，快说你的快讯吧。好的，《The Alliance》第一季，第四集。
I'm listening. This is written by Mike Schur and directed by Brian Gordon. Little bit of trivia, Mike Schur plays Moe's on our show. He does, he plays Moe's. Yeah, not yet, but. Not yet, and he's also just insanely talented. I mean, you know, look him up on IMDB.
我在听。这一集由Mike Schur编剧，Brian Gordon执导。一点小花絮，Mike Schur在我们的剧中扮演Mose。他确实扮演Mose。是的，还没到那个时候，但是。还没到，而且他简直是天才。我是说，你知道，去IMDB上查查他。
He's like writing everywhere, he's everywhere. Yeah, he produces a million amazing television shows. If you're watching a television show and you love it, Mike Schur probably made it. Mike Schur's probably doing it. Yes. So I'm gonna start with a synopsis on this episode. I know we usually start with our fast facts.
他到处都在写剧本，他无处不在。是的，他制作了数百万部精彩的电视剧。如果你正在看一部电视剧并且很喜欢它，Mike Schur可能就是制作人。Mike Schur可能就在做这件事。是的。所以我要从这一集的剧情简介开始。我知道我们通常从快讯开始。
Oh my god, what are you going, rogue? What's wrong with you? I know, I'm refusing to allow any chitchat. I'm starting with a synopsis. You're like in a black shirt with a black hoodie. You've got camel pants. What's happening? Are you taking a kickboxing class or something?
天哪，你要干什么，搞叛逆吗？你怎么了？我知道，我拒绝任何闲聊。我要从剧情简介开始。你穿着黑色衬衫，外面套着黑色连帽衫。你穿着卡其裤。发生什么事了？你在上跆拳道课还是什么的？
You know I took my kickboxing yesterday. I know, I know. So I'm feeling very tough. I know, you're my kickboxing yesterday. I know, I know. You're a badass. I know, you're very tough. All right, synopsis. So this episode has two basic storylines. One, in an attempt to raise morale, Michael insists on throwing a birthday party,
你知道我昨天去上跆拳道课了。我知道，我知道。所以我感觉很强硬。我知道，你昨天去上跆拳道课了。我知道，我知道。你是个狠角色。我知道，你很强硬。好了。剧情简介。所以这一集有两条基本的故事线。第一，为了提振士气，Michael坚持要举办生日派对，
even though it's no one's birthday. It's no one's birthday. The closest birthday is Meredith, so it's next month, but he insists on throwing her birthday party. And then at the same time, Jim and Dwight form an alliance. Dwight is worried about the rumor downsizing, and so he goes to Jim and suggests they form an alliance. And this is like candy for Jim.
尽管根本没人过生日。根本没人过生日。最近的生日是Meredith的，所以是在下个月，但他坚持要给她办生日派对。与此同时，Jim和Dwight结成了联盟。Dwight担心裁员的传言，所以他去找Jim，建议他们结盟。这对Jim来说简直是糖果。
He's like, oh my God. Yes. Oh my God, this is such a great opportunity to mess with Dwight. Both of these themes are because people are afraid that the office is being downsized. This is a big theme of the first season of The Office. And so Michael thinks the answer is to throw a party and Dwight thinks the answer is to form an alliance and spy on his coworkers. Yes. You know, it's not Meredith's birthday, right? But we sort of forced this party, but it is Ryan the Tip's birthday.
他心想，天哪。是的。天哪，这是一个捉弄Dwight的绝佳机会。这两个主题都是因为人们担心办公室会被裁员。这是《办公室》第一季的一个大主题。所以Michael认为答案是举办派对，而Dwight认为答案是结盟并监视他的同事。是的。你知道，那不是Meredith的生日，对吧？但我们强行办了这个派对，不过那天确实是Ryan the Temp的生日。
Oh, yes. That's a little nugget at the end of the episode. It's such a great reveal at the end. Okay, I didn't mean to jump ahead. Okay. That's all right. Well, I'm going to give a little fast fact. So fast facts for anyone who's new to listening.
哦，是的。那是这一集结尾的一个小彩蛋。结尾的那个揭秘太棒了。好的，我不是故意要跳过剧情的。好的。没关系。好吧，我要给出一个小快讯。所以对于任何新听众来说，快讯就是，
These are just a few fun facts about an episode that sort of are overreaching. They apply to the whole episode rather than just one scene. And for those of you just tuning in, Jenna came up with the idea of fast facts. That's right. And she really loves it. And I call her keeper of the notes. She is keeper of the notes, keeper of the records. She loves the list. Yes, Angela. She loves the list.
这些只是一些关于这一集的有趣事实，它们比较宏观。它们适用于整集，而不仅仅是某一个场景。对于那些刚收听的人，Jenna想出了快讯这个点子。没错。她真的很喜欢它。我叫她笔记保管员。她是笔记保管员，记录保管员。她喜欢列表。是的，Angela。她喜欢列表。
Anyone who has been listening regularly knows these two things. Oh, Jenna just cut some eyes at me. I'm telling you, the lady is sassy today. Well, and now we also know you have good hair today. OK, the first fast fact is that this episode was inspired by the television show, Survivor. Yes. Yes, the writing staff watched a bunch of episodes of Survivor,
任何经常收听的人都知道这两件事。哦，Jenna刚才瞪了我一眼。我告诉你，这位女士今天很傲慢。好吧，现在我们也知道你今天发型很棒了。OK，第一个快讯是这一集受到了电视节目《幸存者》的启发。是的。是的，编剧团队看了很多集《幸存者》，
and they did this so that they could properly satirize the way people talk about alliances and this idea of, you know, Ganging up against other people. And also though, you have to mention that our cameraman, Randall Einhorn and Matt Sohn, their background was Survivor. Yes, they were camera operators on Survivor, which for me, as a huge Survivor fan, You're a huge Survivor, which for me, as a huge Survivor fan. You're a huge Survivor fan. You guys, Jeff Probst officiated my wedding.
他们这样做是为了能够恰当地讽刺人们谈论联盟的方式，以及这种“联合起来对抗其他人”的想法。而且，你必须提到我们的摄影师，Randall Einhorn和Matt Sohn，他们的背景就是《幸存者》。是的，他们是《幸存者》的摄影师，对于我这个《幸存者》的超级粉丝来说，你是个超级粉丝，对于我这个《幸存者》的超级粉丝来说。你是个超级粉丝。伙计们，Jeff Probst主持了我的婚礼。
Now, this is something that, you know. This is true. Now, here's the thing. If you know Jenna, and she's like from St. Louis, she's a good Midwest gal. And I remember when you were planning your wedding, and you were like, Jeff Probst is going to officiate. And I was like, the guy from Survivor?
现在，这是一件，你知道的。这是真的。现在，事情是这样的。如果你了解Jenna，她是来自圣路易斯的，是个很好的中西部女孩。我记得你在筹划婚礼的时候，你说Jeff Probst要来主持。我就说，那个《幸存者》里的家伙？
What is happening? So here's what happened. My now husband, Lee, and I, we were at an Emmys party. Now, I know out there people think that when you go to these parties, you become friends with people. But you really don't. You kind of hobnob.
发生什么事了？所以事情是这样的。我和我现在的丈夫Lee，我们在一个艾美奖派对上。现在，我知道外面的人认为当你去这些派对时，你会和人们成为朋友。但你真的不会。你只是去社交。
You maybe take a picture, and then you never see them again. And you sort of stick with the people you already knew. Oh my gosh, I just would always sit like next to like Brian and Oscar and you and like I was terrified to like go meet people. You're better at it. I think you're better at it. Am I? Yes. Remember when you made me go up to Meryl Streep? That's a story for later. Yeah. And Amy Adams and And I said nothing. I look like such a dork. I just walked up and was like, buh. We had to meet Meryl Streep. I'm sorry, if you have a chance to meet Meryl Streep, you don't let that go.
你可能会拍张照，然后就再也见不到他们了。你通常还是和已经认识的人待在一起。天哪，我总是坐在Brian和Oscar和你旁边，我当时害怕去见别人。你更擅长这个。我觉得你更擅长。是吗？记得你让我去找Meryl Streep吗？那是后话了。是的。还有Amy Adams和，我什么都没说。我看起来像个呆子。我只是走过去，然后说，呃。我们必须去见Meryl Streep。抱歉，如果你有机会见到Meryl Streep，你不能错过。
Well, anyway, that's a great story, but we'll save it. OK, well, put a pin in that. So I ended up approaching Jeff Probst at this party. See? You would approach Jeff Probst. I would never go up to him. OK, go on. And I told him that I was a huge Survivor fan, and I was.
好吧，无论如何，那是个很棒的故事，但我们先留着。OK，好吧，先记下这个。所以我最终在那个派对上接近了Jeff Probst。看？你会去接近Jeff Probst。我永远不会去找他。OK，继续。我告诉他我是《幸存者》的超级粉丝，我确实是。
And we ended up really hitting it off, especially Jeff and my then-fiancee Lee really hit it off because they had tennis in common. They played tennis together. Oh, they were tennis pals. Yeah. So after this party, they ended up becoming tennis pals, and then we started going to dinners, couples dinners. Jeff's wife is so lovely.
我们最终真的很投缘，尤其是Jeff和我当时的未婚夫Lee真的很投缘，因为他们有共同的爱好——网球。他们一起打网球。哦，他们是网球伙伴。是的。所以在那次派对之后，他们最终成了网球伙伴，然后我们开始一起吃晚餐，情侣晚餐。Jeff的妻子非常可爱。
Her name is Lisa. So we just ended up becoming great friends with them. And at one of our dinners, Jeff said that he was nervous because that upcoming weekend, he was going to be officiating a friend's wedding. And you were like, ding, ding, ding, ding. Jeff Probst is the type of guy where he is really caring and he's a, has a sort of just like a spiritual soul. I'll tell you one thing. Kind of like Rainn Wilson, right? Yes. I'll tell you one thing.
她叫Lisa。所以我们最终和他们成了好朋友。在一次晚餐时，Jeff说他很紧张，因为那个周末他要主持一个朋友的婚礼。你就说，叮，叮，叮，叮。Jeff Probst是那种非常关心他人的人，他有一种，某种精神上的灵魂。我告诉你一件事。有点像Rainn Wilson，对吧？是的。我告诉你一件事。
When you talk to someone like Jeff or Rainn, you feel like you're the only person in the room. Yes. And they're truly interested in you. They really want to know you. They care about what you care about. They're interested in you. And I thought, that's the kind of person
当你和像Jeff或Rainn这样的人交谈时，你会觉得你是房间里唯一的人。是的。他们真的对你感兴趣。他们真的想了解你。他们关心你在乎的事情。他们对你感兴趣。我想，那就是那种
you want to officiate your wedding. You want that kind of soulful, caring person. But then also, he's a host. So he's comfortable commanding attention from a group of people. And it was awesome. You were there, Angela. It was awesome.
你想让他主持你婚礼的人。你想要那种有灵魂、有爱心的人。但同时，他是个主持人。所以他很擅长掌控一群人的注意力。这太棒了。你在场，Angela。这太棒了。
I was there. Here's my one story from your wedding. Jeff Probst, before your wedding, called me. He got my phone number from you and was like, can you tell me any stories about Jenna that you know from the years? And I was supposed to give a speech at your wedding, a toast. I was going to give a toast. You had asked me to give a toast. And I sort of told Jeff some of my stories about you that I was going to have in my toast. Oh no. And he stole them. He took some of my bits. And so then, like
我在场。这是我关于你婚礼的一个故事。Jeff Probst在你的婚礼前给我打了电话。他从你那里拿到了我的电话号码，然后问，你能告诉我一些你认识Jenna多年来的故事吗？我本应在你的婚礼上致辞，祝酒。我要祝酒。你让我祝酒。我把一些关于你的故事告诉了Jeff，那些我打算在祝酒词里讲的故事。哦，不。他偷走了它们。他拿走了一些我的梗。所以当
when I got up to give my toast, I don't know if you remember, I'm like, I'm going to say a few things. I mean, Jeff Probst pretty much stole all my stuff, but whatever. And I like called him out for stealing my bits. So as you were watching the wedding, all you were thinking was like that he kept stealing your stuff. Yes. Dang it. Propsti. I told you and I called him Propsti. I made up a nickname for him. I'm sure he loved it. All right. Next fast fact. What? The original cut of this episode came in at 40 minutes, which is way too long because for a show to air on television on network TV, it can only be 20 minutes and 30 seconds.
我站起来祝酒时，我不记得你记不记得了，我说，我要说几件事。我是说，Jeff Probst几乎偷走了我所有的东西，但无所谓。我当众揭穿了他偷我梗的事。所以当你看着婚礼时，你脑子里想的只是他一直在偷你的东西。是的。该死的。Propsti。我告诉过你，我叫他Propsti。我给他起了个绰号。我相信他很喜欢。好了。下一个快讯。什么？这一集的原始剪辑时长为40分钟，这太长了，因为一部要在电视网播出的节目，只能有20分30秒。
Well, that's crazy. Because you need room for the commercials. Hey, network TV people, I just have a little tip for you. And I know you want me to weigh in on things. Change up your format. I know, because they had to cut out like half of what they wanted to cut. And Greg considered splitting this into two episodes. I wish they could take all the stuff they cut out
嗯，这太疯狂了。因为你需要留出广告时间。嘿，电视网的人们，我给你们一个小建议。我知道你们想让我发表意见。改变你们的格式。我知道，因为他们不得不剪掉他们想剪掉的一半内容。Greg考虑过把这一集拆分成两集。我希望他们能把剪掉的所有东西
and re-release it all. Wouldn't that be so fun? I will tell you, on the Season 1 DVD, they have the deleted scenes from this episode, and they are delightful. I watched them, and most of what was cut out were really funny kind of general office life scenes.
都重新发布出来。那不是很有趣吗？我告诉你，在第一季的DVD上，有这一集的删减片段，它们非常令人愉快。我看了，大部分被剪掉的都是非常有趣的普通办公室生活场景。
So there was this great bit between Jim and Dwight where Dwight is changing his password, where he's going on and on about how his password on his computer is the best and Jim keeps guessing it. He's like, is it Frodo? And it is. And it is. And then there's another really great one of Dwight just cleaning out the fridge in the break room and he throws away Jim's tuna sandwich.
有一个Jim和Dwight之间很棒的片段，Dwight在改密码，他喋喋不休地说他的电脑密码是最好的，Jim一直在猜。他说，是Frodo吗？结果真的是。真的是。还有一个很棒的片段是Dwight在清理休息室的冰箱，他扔掉了Jim的金枪鱼三明治。
There was also a really great scene that when I was watching this deleted scene, I remembered shooting and it was so funny of Michael coaching Pam on how to answer the phone with a smile. Oh my Lord. He said that she sounded really gloomy. And he then stands by her desk and waits for the phone to ring. And there's just these long pauses. Awkward pauses. And then he does this funny thing where he puts his hands in front of his face and he
还有一个非常棒的场景，当我看到这个删减片段时，我记得拍摄过，Michael指导Pam如何带着微笑接电话，太搞笑了。哦，天哪。他说她听起来真的很忧郁。然后他站在她的办公桌旁，等着电话响。中间有很长的停顿。尴尬的停顿。然后他做了这个有趣的动作，把手放在脸前，
says, tell me if I'm smiling or not. Oh my Lord. He's like, Dunder Mifflin, this is Michael. And she's like, yes, you're smiling. And then he's like, Dunder Mifflin, this is Michael. And I'm like, not smiling. And he's like, you hear the difference? And then I have this line where I'm like, that was a really great example. Thank you. But so there is a place if you're interested, the season one DVD has all of these deleted scenes on it. And you
说，告诉我我是在微笑还是没在微笑。哦，天哪。他说，Dunder Mifflin，我是Michael。她说，是的，你在微笑。然后他说，Dunder Mifflin，我是Michael。我说，没在微笑。他说，你听出区别了吗？然后我有一句台词，我说，那是个很好的例子。谢谢。但如果你感兴趣的话，第一季的DVD上有所有这些删减片段。而且你
know, by the way, the reason Greg couldn't split this up into two episodes, he thought of doing one episode that was just about throwing the birthday party and one episode that was just about the Alliance, the big prank. And then you could have filled it out with some of these general office life scenes. The problem was at the end of the episode, we all are have birthday hats. We all all are have birthday hats. We all have cake and birthday hats. And so the end of the Alliance part ends with birthday hats. And so he couldn't do it.
知道，顺便说一下，Greg不能把这一集拆成两集的原因是，他想过拍一集只关于举办生日派对，另一集只关于联盟，那个大恶作剧。然后你可以用一些这些普通的办公室生活场景来填充。问题是，在这一集的结尾，我们都戴着生日帽。我们都戴着生日帽。我们都有蛋糕和生日帽。所以联盟部分的结尾是以生日帽结束的。所以他没法拆分。
Jenna, I have some trivia on my note cards, but you need to tell me when you're done with your fast facts. So I have one more fast fact. I don't want to mess up your list. I see. I have. Don't look at my note cards. I can see one of my fast facts on your note cards.
Jenna，我的笔记卡上有一些花絮，但你需要告诉我你什么时候讲完快讯。所以我还有一个快讯。我不想弄乱你的列表。我明白了。我有。别看我的笔记卡。我能在你的笔记卡上看到我的一个快讯。
Well, stop looking at my homework. Well, my goodness. Well, excuse me, Angela. Here's my last fast fact. Okay, do it. Near and dear to my heart and yours. This is the first time we meet the party planning committee. The PPC.
好吧，别看我的家庭作业了。天哪。好吧，打扰一下，Angela。这是我的最后一个快讯。OK，说吧。对我俩来说都很亲切。这是我们第一次见到派对策划委员会。PPC。
The PPC. Oh my gosh, just years of just lovely memories of us planning ridiculous parties. Oh my gosh. I remember that because I remember that there was just a tiny bit that was scripted. Yes. And then Greg told us, Greg Daniels said, guys,
PPC。天哪，多年来我们策划荒谬派对的美好回忆。天哪。我记得那个，因为我记得只有一小部分是有剧本的。是的。然后Greg告诉我们，Greg Daniels说，伙计们，
just keep planning the party. Yeah, just, just. We're going to record you. Yes. And that's when Phyllis was naming colors, like what color streamers. And then we did this whole like we did a whole other tangent about do we say happy birthday or do we say surprise? Or do we say happy birthday surprise or surprise? Who would say that? You're right. We should start with surprise.
继续策划派对。是的，继续。我们要录下你们。是的。那就是Phyllis在命名颜色的时候，比如什么颜色的彩带。然后我们做了整个，我们做了另一个关于我们是说“生日快乐”还是说“惊喜”的切线。或者我们说“生日快乐惊喜”还是“惊喜”？谁会那么说？你是对的。我们应该从“惊喜”开始。
You say surprise first. And then Pam's just caught in the middle of you and Phyllis. And I love the dynamic of your subtle bullying of Phyllis. Yes. Your famous line, I think green is kind of horish, is in this episode. Yes. And Phyllis is of of course, wearing green. And then I throw her under the bus at the end.
你先说“惊喜”。然后Pam就夹在你和Phyllis中间。我喜欢你对Phyllis那种微妙霸凌的动态。是的。你那句名言，“我觉得绿色有点像妓女”，就在这一集里。是的。Phyllis当然穿着绿色。然后我在最后把她推向了风口浪尖。
I blame her for the lame streamers, the red streamers. I just love all of it. And there was so much that was there that got cut. And I know why. I mean, no one wants to watch like 20 minutes of us trying to plan a party. But it was so fun. I always felt like there could be a spinoff, like a web special called the Party Planning
我把糟糕的彩带，红色的彩带归咎于她。我就是喜欢这一切。有很多东西被剪掉了。我知道为什么。我是说，没人想看我们花20分钟策划派对。但这太有趣了。我一直觉得可以有一个衍生剧，比如一个叫《派对策划委员会》的网络特辑。
Committee. The PPC. Oh my gosh. What if there was like this cool thing where they like uncovered all of the like unused footage of us planning parties. Oh my God. That's got to exist in a vault somewhere. Somewhere.
PPC。天哪。如果有一个很酷的东西，他们挖掘出所有我们策划派对的未用素材，那会怎样？天哪。那一定存在于某个保险库里。某个地方。
I would totally want to see it, but we did. We had so much fun. And we took such long pauses and it was so boring. It was so boring. And Pam was dying inside. My take on that scene was that I should speak very little. Like how I got roped into being on this committee, I feel like I was forced onto it by Michael. I don't think I volunteered.
我绝对想看，但我们确实做了。我们玩得很开心。我们停顿了很长时间，这太无聊了。太无聊了。Pam在内心深处快死了。我对那个场景的理解是，我应该少说话。就像我怎么被拉进这个委员会的，我觉得我是被Michael强迫加入的。我不觉得我是自愿的。
And I just wanted the meeting to be over. And it didn't, you know, but you have that, have you been in those office? Oh my God, yes. I mean, come on, you and I both temped and we worked in offices. And I mean, yes, you've been in those meetings. It's that famous like line that people say like,
我只是想让会议结束。而且它没有，你知道，但你有过，你参加过那些办公室会议吗？天哪，是的。我是说，拜托，你和我都是临时工，我们在办公室工作过。我是说，是的，你参加过那些会议。这就是人们常说的那句名言，
this whole meeting could have been one email. Yeah, that's that's what it is. You know, I have to point out my hairstyle in this party planning committee scene because that hairstyle was bonkers crazy. It was like, I don't know, we took two pieces and we twisted it back to the back of my head. And then we did a low ponytail that connected it. And I had so many rubber bands and pins holding it. And then I had one piece that kept flopping out and it drove me crazy. And by the end of the episode, I was like, I don't ever want this.
“整个会议本可以通过一封电子邮件解决。”是的，就是那样。你知道，我必须指出我在这个派对策划委员会场景中的发型，因为那个发型简直疯了。我不知道，我们取了两缕头发，把它扭到脑后。然后我们做了一个连接它的低马尾。我用了好多橡皮筋和发夹固定它。然后我有一缕头发一直掉下来，这让我快疯了。到这一集结束时，我就想，我再也不要这样了。
I can't do this again. I can't have this hairstyle again. You can do whatever you want, but this weird multiple rubber band, I can't do it again. Angela, I feel like we've come full circle here. We started by speaking about your hair and now we're speaking about your hair again. It's almost like, it's almost perfect. This must make you so happy, Jenna.
我不能再这样了。我不能再留这个发型了。你想做什么都可以，但这个奇怪的多重橡皮筋发型，我不能再留了。Angela，我觉得我们在这里兜了一圈。我们开始时在谈论你的头发，现在我们又在谈论你的头发了。这几乎是，几乎是完美的。这一定让你很高兴，Jenna。
It does. And I take it back. I think that you were right to have that banter. I will take that, Jenna Fisher. Let's take a break and then we'll come back and we'll start to really dive into this episode scene by scene. Okay. Oh, let's do it. This episode is brought to you by Missouri.
确实。我收回前言。我觉得你刚才的调侃是对的。我接受了，Jenna Fisher。让我们休息一下，然后回来，开始真正深入解析这一集的每一个场景。好的。哦，让我们开始吧。本集由Missouri赞助。
From November 25 to December 2, get 25% off everything on orders over $150 in Missouri's biggest sale ever. From bold hoops to minimalist stacks, Missouri has something for everyone. Missouri makes handcrafted fine jewelry for every day made with responsibly sourced materials. So you can look and feel good about gifting and wearing them. Shop your wishlist 25% off at majorey.com today.
从11月25日到12月2日，在Missouri有史以来最大的促销活动中，订单满150美元即可享受全场75折优惠。从大胆的圆环耳饰到极简的叠戴款式，Missouri能满足每个人的需求。Missouri为日常佩戴制作手工精美首饰，采用负责任的材料。所以您在赠送和佩戴时都能感到舒心。今天就访问majorey.com，以75折优惠购买您的心愿单商品。
Light up Black Friday with Freedom Mobile and get 50 gigs to use in Canada, the U.S. and Mexico for just $35 a month for 18 months. Plus, get a one-time gift of 5 gigs of Rome Beyond Data. Conditions apply. Details at FreedomMobile.ca. your stairs. And to you, when you spend $25 on McDonald's gift cards in restaurants, get a coupon for a free Big Mac or McChicken. See details at participating McDonald's restaurants. Well, welcome back. Welcome back. We are talking about the Alliance. Let's get into it, Jenna.
用Freedom Mobile点亮黑色星期五，每月仅需35美元，即可获得50GB流量，可在加拿大、美国和墨西哥使用，为期18个月。此外，还可获得一次性赠送的5GB漫游数据。适用条件。详情请见FreedomMobile.ca。你的楼梯。而且，当您在餐厅消费25美元的麦当劳礼品卡时，可获得一张免费巨无霸或麦香鸡的优惠券。详情请见参与活动的麦当劳餐厅。好吧，欢迎回来。欢迎回来。我们正在谈论《The Alliance》。让我们开始吧，Jenna。
All right. The very first scene in this episode is Dwight waiting outside of the bathroom to confront Michael about the downsizing rumors. And I just have to say, we do this a lot to Michael and it always makes me laugh. First of all, how much time does he spend in the bathroom? And whenever people want to talk to them, they, because this already happened, Oscar waits outside the bathroom to confront him. Yes. We're always bombarding him outside of the restroom.
好的。这一集的第一幕是Dwight在洗手间外等着，要就裁员传言与Michael对质。我不得不说，我们经常对Michael做这种事，这总是让我发笑。首先，他在洗手间里花了多少时间？每当人们想和他谈话时，他们，因为这已经发生过了，Oscar在洗手间外等他。是的。我们总是围攻他，就在洗手间外面。
Well, I think it's because Michael is always avoiding us. He's like, he always is avoiding work, right? Yes, unless he has a joke to tell or unless he has good news. Yes, otherwise he hides. And so people wait for him outside of the bathroom and he's always startled. I have a lot of empathy for him because as a mother, I feel like every time I go to the bathroom, someone is literally waiting outside the door for me.
嗯，我想这是因为Michael总是躲着我们。他总是逃避工作，对吧？是的，除非他有笑话要讲，或者除非他有好消息。是的，否则他就躲起来。所以人们在洗手间外等他，他总是被吓一跳。我对他很有同情心，因为作为一个母亲，我觉得每次我去洗手间，都有人真的在门外等着我。
Always. Always. I don't understand it. What is that? Why can't mothers go to the bathroom without someone outside the door? I don't know. You know, I have such like empathy for my parents now in a different way. I remember my dad going to the bathroom one time and I was outside the door like, and I think I was like messing with the door. I was like doing like click, click, click, click on the door, click, click. And my my dad was like I'm just trying to go to the bathroom and I was like hey dad he's like he just needed five minutes just five minutes five minutes my kids slide things under the door always slide things under the door like that drawing couldn't wait no or they just
总是。总是。我不明白。这是什么？为什么母亲去洗手间时，门外不能没人？我不知道。你知道，我现在以一种不同的方式对我的父母很有同情心。我记得我爸爸有一次去洗手间，我在门外，我想我当时在捣乱门。我在门上做“咔哒，咔哒，咔哒，咔哒”的声音，咔哒，咔哒。我爸爸说，我只是想去洗手间，我说，嘿爸爸，他只是需要五分钟，就五分钟，五分钟。我的孩子们总是把东西从门缝里塞进来，总是把东西塞进来，就像那幅画，等不及了，不，或者他们只是
open the door or they just come on in I know I. I know. Okay, sorry. Okay, anyway, poor Michael is accosted as he comes out of the bathroom once again. I have like a fun little Dwight thing that I noticed in rewatching this. What? So it is such a joy for me to go back and rewatch these episodes. I know you're having a lot of fun with it too, but I always thought the first bobblehead that Dwight ever had was the one that my character gave him for Valentines. Really? Of himself.
打开门，或者他们直接进来。我知道我。我知道。好的，抱歉。好的，无论如何，可怜的Michael再次在走出洗手间时被纠缠。我在重温这一集时注意到了一个关于Dwight的有趣小细节。什么？所以对我来说，回去重温这些剧集是一种乐趣。我知道你也很享受，但我一直以为Dwight拥有的第一个摇头娃娃是我角色在情人节送给他的那个。真的吗？他自己的。
I knew that wasn't true. What? Yes, the reason your character made him a bobblehead of himself was because of his love of bobbleheads. It's just maybe something you want to look into for your character, Anne. What? Really? Yes. That's...
我知道那不是真的。什么？是的，你的角色给他做一个他自己的摇头娃娃，是因为他热爱摇头娃娃。这可能就是你想要为你的角色Anne研究的东西。什么？真的吗？是的。那是……
Was it a known thing that Dwight loved bobbleheads? Yes, he has them on his desk. Oh my God. Wow. How did I miss that? Shinnit is now looking at me like I might need to take medication for something. Oh my God. That just occurred to you now in the rewatch?
Dwight热爱摇头娃娃是众所周知的事吗？是的，他的桌子上就有。天哪。哇。我怎么会错过那个？Shinnit现在看着我，好像我可能需要吃药治疗什么东西。天哪。那直到现在重温时才发生在你身上？
That just occurred to me. I thought he was so excited because I gave him a bobblehead. Oh my god. Oh my lord. I am a dingbat. Okay. I wrote on my note card. You have to hear what I wrote. I'm such an idiot. Dwight has a bunch of bobbleheads! Exclamation point!
那直到现在才发生在我身上。我以为他那么兴奋是因为我送了他一个摇头娃娃。天哪。哦，我的天。我是个笨蛋。我在我的笔记卡上写了。你必须听听我写了什么。我真是个白痴。Dwight有一堆摇头娃娃！感叹号！
Baseball team! I counted six bobbleheads! Are they from the Phillies? Oh my God. How many times did I walk past his desk and I didn't notice that. Because he collected bobbleheads, your character makes him a bobblehead of himself. That's where your character got the idea. It's a good thing you don character got the idea. I hit my head. It's a good thing you don't write the show.
棒球队！我数了六个摇头娃娃！它们是费城人队的吗？天哪。我多少次走过他的桌子，我竟然没注意到。因为他收集摇头娃娃，你的角色才给他做一个他自己的摇头娃娃。这就是你角色获得灵感的地方。真庆幸你没写这个剧。
I hit my head on the microphone. Oh my God. How did I miss that? So this I think is an example of how fans of the show might know it better than some of the people on it. Oh my God. As Angela is pointing out a fact of the show that landed on everyone else but her. I was so excited. Look at my note cards.
我撞到麦克风上了。天哪。我怎么会错过那个？所以这我认为是一个例子，说明剧集的粉丝可能比剧中的一些人更了解它。天哪。正如Angela指出的那样，剧集的一个事实被所有人注意到了，除了她。我太兴奋了。看看我的笔记卡。
So many exclamation points, guys. I put so many, six bobbleheads. They're all baseball players. I do have some other good note cards coming up. Let's see another note card. We'll decide. Okay. All right, sassy pants.
伙计们，我加了好多感叹号。我写了好多，六个摇头娃娃。它们都是棒球运动员。我确实还有一些其他好的笔记卡要讲。让我们看另一张笔记卡。我们决定。好的。好的。傲慢的家伙。
I put an asterisk by this one because I thought it was so good. Do you know that there is a continuity error? Aha! Oh, look at your face now, Jenna Fisher. Alright, I don't have this in my note. Oh, I know. There's a continuity error. What is it? And it's in accounting at seven minutes. At seven minutes, Michael is talking about what he's going to write on the birthday birthday card. And he says, and you know what guys, I have set the bar really high. Oh, Sam, pull it up, pull it up on the screen.
我给这张加了星号，因为我觉得它太好了。你知道有一个连续性错误吗？啊哈！哦，看看你现在的脸，Jenna Fisher。好吧，我的笔记里没有这个。哦，我知道。有一个连续性错误。是什么？它在7分钟时的会计部。在7分钟时，Michael正在谈论他要在生日贺卡上写什么。他说，你知道吗伙计们，我把标准定得很高。哦，Sam，把它调出来，把它调出来。
Sam is here in the booth, he's gonna show Jenna. I'm at the copier at the beginning of this talking head behind Michael. I'm in my beige sweater that I wear through the whole episode with my crazy ponytail. All right. And then it cuts to me at my desk during his talking head and I'm in a white t-shirt, a white button down with a black sweater vest and a different hairstyle.
Sam在隔间里，他要给Jenna看。在Michael的独白开始时，我在复印机旁，Michael身后。我穿着那件我在整集中都穿的米色毛衣，扎着疯狂的马尾辫。好的。然后镜头切到他的独白时我在桌子旁，我穿着一件白色T恤，一件白色纽扣衬衫，外面套着黑色毛衣背心，发型也不一样。
They edited in a different piece of footage to cut to and I'm completely- You're in a different outfit. Completely from a different episode. I'm in a white button down and a black sweater I'm looking at it now. I see it beige sweater. Okay over Michael's shoulder through the window at the copier Jim wrote Meredith I heard you're turning 46, but come on. You're an accountant. Just fudge the numbers Not bad pretty funny see me at the copier. I don't appreciate condoning corporate fraud though. Now. I leave the copier I go to my desk.
他们剪辑了另一段素材切进去，我完全——你穿着不同的衣服。完全来自另一集。我穿着白色纽扣衬衫和黑色毛衣，我现在看到了。我看到了，米色毛衣。好的，在Michael肩膀上方，透过窗户，在复印机旁，Jim写道：Meredith，我听说你46岁了，但拜托。你是个会计。把数字改改吧。不错，挺有趣的。看到我在复印机旁了吗？我不赞成纵容企业欺诈。现在。我离开复印机，去我的桌子。
Go to your desk. This is apparently when you're changing clothes. Yes. So what are you doing back there? You're putting on a... People out there are expecting. I've already set the bar really high. Oh, look at that!
去你的桌子。这显然是你换衣服的时候。是的。那你后面在干什么？你在穿一件……外面的人都在期待。我已经把标准定得很高了。哦，看那个！
Look at that, I'm in a completely different outfit. Ha ha. Whoa, I have something else to talk about in this scene. But okay, can you just say though, okay, maybe I fumbled the bobblehead moment, but I did catch a continuity error. Okay, I will not. Suck it, suck it. Okay, I'm giving that to you.
看那个，我穿着完全不同的衣服。哈哈。哇，我还有别的事要在这个场景里谈。但是好的，你能说一下吗，好的，也许我在摇头娃娃那一刻搞砸了，但我确实抓到了一个连续性错误。好的，我不会。去死吧，去死吧。好的，我承认了。
I didn't see it. I didn't see it. Thank you. You saw it. I saw something. I did it. So you saw something too. What did you see?
我没看到。我没看到。谢谢。你看到了。我看到了什么。我做到了。所以你也看到了什么。你看到了什么？
Well, I'm not going to take credit for this. This was from isrosis on Twitter. IZrosis, capital IZrosis on Twitter mentions that in this moment when Michael's reading Jim's comment, Jim references that Meredith is an accountant. Yeah. Wait, we just watched the scene and you didn't catch that. Because I was looking at my outfit. You were looking at your outfit.
好吧，我可不敢居功。这是推特上的isrosis提到的。推特上的IZrosis，大写的IZrosis提到，在迈克尔读吉姆评论的那一刻，吉姆提到梅雷迪思是会计。是的。等等，我们刚看了那一幕，你没注意到吗？因为我当时在看我的衣服。你在看你的衣服。
I was listening to the words and I heard it too. That's just a dig. I heard it as well. So you know, her question was, what's up with that? I thought there were three accountants. Why does he say you're an accountant? Just fudge the numbers. This is another continuity error.
我在听台词，我也听到了。那只是个挖苦。我也听到了。所以你知道，她的问题是，那是怎么回事？我以为有三个会计。他为什么说你是会计？只是胡乱凑数。这是另一个连续性错误。
Another. So here's something that I have at home. Okay. That is an amazing thing. It's called the show Bible. Okay. Do you know what a show Bible is for a TV show? I do. Okay, you know, let's explain it to people. A show Bible is a giant document. I mean, like thousands of pages. It looks like a phone book. It looks like a phone book. And in it, it lists every character and every fact about them. And every episode, if we learn something new about them, it gets put in the Bible. Yes. So it says our job, it says our relationships to people. I have a copy of the show Bible for the office.
又一个。这是我家里有的东西。好吧。那是个了不起的东西。它叫剧集圣经。好吧。你知道电视剧的剧集圣经是什么吗？我知道。好吧，你知道，让我们给人们解释一下。剧集圣经是一份巨大的文档。我是说，几千页。它看起来像电话簿。它看起来像电话簿。里面列出了每个角色和关于他们的每个事实。每一集，如果我们了解到关于他们的新东西，就会被放进圣经里。是的。所以它写着我们的工作，写着我们与人的关系。我有一份《办公室》的剧集圣经。
Wow. How I got this, I don't know. I mean, there's probably only like two or three of them. Yes, I know. And I think I borrowed it. Jenna. Because I, over the summer. And you didn't give it back?
哇。我是怎么得到它的，我不知道。我是说，可能只有两三本。是的，我知道。我想我是借来的。珍娜。因为我，在夏天的时候。你没还回去？
Yes, I think this is true. Over the summer from season eight to season nine, Greg Daniels came to John and I and asked us if we had any ideas for our final character arc in season nine. And he said, if it helps you, you can borrow the show Bible. So wait, Greg, I think Jenna has your show. I've got if you've been looking for it.
是的，我想这是真的。在第八季到第九季之间的那个夏天，格雷格·丹尼尔斯来找我和约翰，问我们对第九季最终角色弧线有什么想法。他说，如果对你有帮助，你可以借用剧集圣经。所以等等，格雷格，我想珍娜有你的剧集圣经。如果你一直在找它，我这儿有。
Maybe I shouldn't be saying this out loud because I really love my show Bible. I could probably make a copy before I return it. I think you should make a copy. According to the show Bible, Meredith's job is customer service rep slash supplier relations. She is not an accountant. No, she's not an accountant. No, and Isrosis said, what is her job? Because I know she's not an accountant.
也许我不该大声说出来，因为我真的很喜欢我的剧集圣经。我可以在归还之前复印一份。我觉得你应该复印一份。根据剧集圣经，梅雷迪思的工作是客户服务代表兼供应商关系。她不是会计。不，她不是会计。不，Isrosis说，她的工作是什么？因为我知道她不是会计。
So that's your answer. Also, Kelly is a customer service rep. And I remember there was a bit of a story where we put her back in that other room in the annex back by Toby because she talked too much. She was too chatty, and she was bothering Meredith. So they moved her back there. But really, the reason she sat back there
所以这就是你的答案。另外，凯利是客户服务代表。我记得有个小故事，我们把她调回了托比后面那个隔间，因为她话太多了。她太爱聊天了，打扰到了梅雷迪思。所以他们把她调到了后面。但实际上，她坐在那里的原因是
was because she was a writer, and they didn't want her to waste her writing time doing background work. Yeah, so she had to be separated so she could get out to write. But they made it a story point. You know what Greg said one time, we had a new writer one season and he was talking to me, they were gonna be giving like food in the episode
因为她是编剧，他们不想让她把写作时间浪费在做背景工作上。是的，所以她必须被隔开，这样她才能出去写作。但他们把它变成了一个故事点。你知道格雷格有一次说什么吗，有一季我们有个新编剧，他在跟我说话，他们要在那一集里提供食物
and they handed me like this steak or whatever and I was like, well, my character's a vegetarian. And he was like, oh, I didn't realize that. And I was like, yeah, my character is a vegetarian. And then Greg was like standing next to me and he was like, oh, I didn't realize that. And I was like, yeah, my character is a vegetarian. And then Greg was standing next to me, and he was like, you know what? Anything you want to know about each of their characters, just go talk to them. They know their character. They know sort of like the canon of all.
他们递给我牛排什么的，我说，嗯，我的角色是素食主义者。他说，哦，我没意识到。我说，是的，我的角色是素食主义者。然后格雷格站在我旁边，他说，哦，我没意识到。我说，是的，我的角色是素食主义者。然后格雷格站在我旁边，他说，你知道吗？任何你想知道的关于他们每个角色的事，直接去问他们。他们了解自己的角色。他们了解所有角色的设定。
They've lived every episode, and they know their individual character story so well. I didn't know your character was a vegetarian. When do we establish that? It's established early on. And then it's throughout all the years. Like at Diwali, I was like, I guess I'll just eat naan. Whatever. Naan? Like there's like a whole thing.
他们经历了每一集，他们非常了解自己角色的故事。我不知道你的角色是素食主义者。我们什么时候确定的？很早就确定了。然后贯穿了所有年份。比如在排灯节，我说，我想我还是吃馕吧。随便吧。馕？就像有一整件事。
Oh, I'm going to look it up in the show Bible. Okay, look it up in the show Bible. Maybe we should, well, let's get back to this episode a little bit. We got on a tangent. Oh, me and you on a tangent? Get out of town. Hard to believe. What are you even talking about? All right, so there's this scene early on where Pam and Michael are stuck in the office together. And I remember I could not get through this scene. There's this never-ending drum roll where Michael wants me to announce who has a birthday coming up. And he also calls you his assistant in this, which I think is hilarious. He has such a grandiose view of his job and who he is.
哦，我要去剧集圣经里查一下。好吧，去剧集圣经里查吧。也许我们应该，好吧，让我们回到这一集来。我们跑题了。哦，我和你跑题了？别开玩笑了。真难相信。你到底在说什么？好吧，所以早些时候有这么一幕，帕姆和迈克尔被困在办公室里。我记得我无法演完这一幕。有个没完没了的鼓点，迈克尔想让我宣布谁快过生日了。他还在这一幕里叫你他的助理，我觉得这太搞笑了。他对自己的工作和身份有着如此宏大的看法。
You are his assistant. You're not front reception for the whole company. You're Michael's assistant. Right. His personal assistant. You're his personal assistant. Which is not true. And he does this never-ending drum roll on the desk that was making me laugh.
你是他的助理。你不是整个公司的前台。你是迈克尔的助理。对。他的私人助理。你是他的私人助理。这不对。他在桌子上敲着没完没了的鼓点，这让我笑个不停。
And he wants me to announce whose birthday is coming up. And I say, there's no birthdays. And he's like, well, next one, next, just who is it? So then I say, well, Meredith's birthday is next month. And then I'm just, I am just giving him nothing in the scene and he starts swooping his phone across my face to see if he can find signs of life. Yes.
他想让我宣布谁快过生日了。我说，没有生日。他说，好吧，下一个，下一个，到底是谁？所以我说，嗯，梅雷迪思的生日在下个月。然后我，我只是在这一幕里什么都没给他，他开始把手机在我脸上晃来晃去，看能不能找到生命迹象。是的。
I cracked up. Oh my gosh. He was so funny when he was doing that. I just remember when I was rewatching this, I just remember losing it. But that's sort of where we set up that storyline, is that we now have to throw a party for Meredith, whose birthday is next month.
我笑喷了。天哪。他做那个动作的时候太搞笑了。我记得重看这一集时，我记得我笑得不行。但这就是我们设定那个故事情节的地方，我们现在必须为梅雷迪思举办派对，她的生日在下个月。
This is like a real dork thing. But when I watch these early scenes of Michael's office, it looks so different over the years. There's that shelf in the corner. He doesn't have the tall standing shelf with two doors. It's a different lower shelf. I don't know if you like look at all that. And I'm like, oh, his office,
这听起来像个书呆子才会做的事。但当我观看迈克尔办公室的这些早期场景时，这些年来它看起来太不一样了。角落里有个架子。他没有那个带两扇门的高立式架子。那是另一个矮架子。我不知道你是否会看这些。我说，哦，他的办公室，
like the furniture in his office keeps changing. This is a super nerdy thing for me to notice, but I mean, I don't notice bobble heads, but if you're gonna- You're gonna notice a major story point. If you're gonna move a cabinet, I'm gonna notice. So the next big sort of plot point scene is Rain asking Jim if he wants to form an alliance.
他办公室里的家具一直在变。这对我来说是个超级书呆子的发现，但我是说，我不注意摇头娃娃，但如果你要——你会注意到一个主要的故事点。如果你要移动柜子，我会注意到的。所以下一个大的情节场景是雷恩问吉姆是否想结盟。
And this produced one of our inside joke lines. He asks him if he wants to form an alliance and Jim pauses and then he says, absolutely I do. And we used to say that to each other on the set. That used to be a thing, absolutely I do. I we used to say that to each other on the set. That used to be a thing. Absolutely. I do. I love this so much because it's just like Jim finally gets to have fun at work. This is like one of his favorite days you would think, right? Because otherwise it's just the monotony of it all. And Dwight does drive him crazy. And he talks about how crazy that Dwight makes him and he
这产生了我们内部笑话台词之一。他问他是否想结盟，吉姆停顿了一下，然后他说，绝对想。我们过去在片场经常对彼此说这句话。那曾经是个梗，绝对想。我过去在片场经常对彼此说这句话。那曾经是个梗。绝对。想。我太喜欢这个了，因为这就像吉姆终于可以在工作中找乐子了。你会觉得这是他最喜欢的日子之一，对吧？因为除此之外，一切都很单调。德怀特确实让他抓狂。他谈到德怀特让他有多疯狂，他
finally gets to like really mess with him at Dwight's invitation. That is the best. He has that talking head where he says, sometimes it's just handed to you. I mean, you're thinking, how can I mess with this guy? And then here this wonderful gift comes. So after they decide to form the alliance, he says, don't tell anyone, you can't tell anyone. Right. Jim's like, of course not. And then Jim immediately comes up to the reception desk and tells me that he's formed an alliance with Dwight. And you see Dwight hovering in the background, listening in, and he wants to get Jim away from me.
终于可以在德怀特的邀请下真的捉弄他了。那是最好的。他有那个谈话头，他说，有时候机会就是送上门的。我是说，你在想，我怎么才能捉弄这家伙？然后这个美妙的礼物就来了。所以他们决定结盟后，他说，别告诉任何人，你不能告诉任何人。对。吉姆说，当然不会。然后吉姆立刻来到前台，告诉我他已经和德怀特结盟了。你看到德怀特在背景里徘徊，偷听，他想把吉姆从我身边拉开。
So he has this line where he's like, Jim, can I talk to you about the paper products? So I listen to the DVD commentary of this. And I guess in that scene, they have a bunch of takes where Rain, every time he would change the end of the line. And I think it was Mike Schur said his favorite alt of that was, Hey, Jim, can I talk to you about the da ba da ba? He just like mumbles something that you couldn't even hear. I love that. I also loved like John Krasinski as Jim. You could just see John, I think because we
所以他有句台词，他说，吉姆，我能跟你谈谈纸制品的事吗？所以我听了这一集的DVD评论。我想在那一幕里，他们拍了很多条，雷恩每次都会改变台词的结尾。我想迈克·舒尔说他最喜欢的替代台词是，嘿，吉姆，我能跟你谈谈那个哒吧哒吧吗？他只是嘟囔了一些你甚至听不清的东西。我喜欢那个。我也喜欢约翰·卡拉辛斯基饰演的吉姆。你可以看到约翰，我想因为我们
know him, having so much fun. When they go into the kitchen and Dwight's like, what are you doing? He's like, I'm working her. He's like, I'm working her. You know, like he's like, I'm on this, okay? Like I just saw John, like our friend John having so much fun in that moment. And it just made me smile. It's so cute the whole way that he is winding Dwight up in this episode. It happens again where he goes into the kitchen
了解他，在那一刻玩得很开心。当他们走进厨房，德怀特问，你在干什么？他说，我在利用她。他说，我在利用她。你知道，就像他说，我搞定了，好吗？就像我看到约翰，我们的朋友约翰在那一刻玩得很开心。这让我笑了。他在这一集里戏弄德怀特的方式太可爱了。这又发生了一次，他走进厨房
where he's supposed to be spying on Toby and Kevin who are having lunch. Oh my god, that conversation is the most ridiculous, like amazing, boring conversation. Yes, and that produced another most frequently quoted inside joke line on The Office, which is when they're talking about the bread, and then John's take on that line, he says, their bread is very good, very good. We would do that all the time. And then here you are, the bread maker. Oh my gosh, pull circle life moment. Guys, my bread is very good.
他本该去监视托比和凯文，他们正在吃午饭。哦天哪，那段对话是最荒谬、最精彩、最无聊的对话。是的，那产生了《办公室》里另一个最常被引用的内部笑话台词，就是当他们谈论面包时，然后约翰对那句台词的处理，他说，他们的面包非常好，非常好。我们经常那样做。然后你就在这里，面包师。哦天哪，圆满的人生时刻。伙计们，我的面包非常好。
Thank you. Also, we cannot not talk about the fact of how eagerly Pam is to join in Jim's prank and becomes a huge participant like in pulling this prank on Dwight. Oh yes, yes. Well this is their opportunity to spend time together. Any opportunity to team up with Jim. I mean, in the deleted scene we established that the phone rings very infrequently. Which we could probably have guessed anyway. This is so much fun for her.
谢谢。另外，我们不能不谈论帕姆是多么热切地想加入吉姆的恶作剧，并成为捉弄德怀特这一恶作剧的巨大参与者。哦是的，是的。好吧，这是他们共度时光的机会。任何与吉姆组队的机会。我是说，在删减片段中我们确定了电话很少响。我们本来也能猜到。这对她来说太有趣了。
She's having so much fun and Jim is just loving it. And his talking head about like how brilliant you were that you just came up, Pam came up with that all on her own. Yeah, when I come up to his desk and I'm like all fraught with it. Oh, I just don't know. Michael's told me so many things and I want to unload all these secrets, but he told me not to. And I'm doing that all so that Dwight can overhear it. Dwight's like jackpot.
她玩得很开心，吉姆也乐在其中。还有他关于你有多聪明的谈话头，帕姆是自己想出来的。是的，当我走到他桌前，我表现得很焦虑。哦，我不知道。迈克尔告诉了我很多事，我想倾诉所有这些秘密，但他告诉我不准说。我做这一切都是为了让德怀特能听到。德怀特就像中了头奖。
But Jim is just so enamored with Pam and the scene. And you know what? I'm a jam fan, you guys. I am. And I love their storyline. I was just like a total fan of them. And I remember like every little nugget they had together. I was like, oh my god. And this is definitely one of those episodes. Should we take a break? I don't know. Do you
但吉姆在这一幕里对帕姆太着迷了。你知道吗，伙计们，我是Jam粉。我是。我喜欢他们的故事情节。我简直是他们的超级粉丝。我记得他们在一起的每一个小片段。我说，哦天哪。这绝对是其中一集。我们休息一下吗？我不知道。你
want to take a break? Please take us to a break. Oh my god. Miami Metro catches killers and they say it takes a village to race one. Anyone knows how powerful urges can be? It's me. Catch Dexter Morgan in a new serial killer origin story. Hunger inside of you. It needs a master. Featuring Patrick Gibson, Christian Slater, special guest star Sarah Michelle Geller with Patrick Dempsey and Michael C. Hall as Dexter's inner voice. I wasn't born a killer. I was made.
想休息一下吗？请带我们去休息。哦天哪。迈阿密大都会警察抓捕杀手，他们说培养一个杀手需要一个村庄。有人知道冲动有多强大吗？是我。在新的连环杀手起源故事中观看德克斯特·摩根。你内心的饥饿。它需要一个主人。由帕特里克·吉布森、克里斯蒂安·史莱特主演，特别客串莎拉·米歇尔·盖拉，帕特里克·德姆西和迈克尔·C·豪尔担任德克斯特的内心独白。我不是天生的杀手。我是被造就的。
Dexter Original Sin, new series streaming December 13th. We're back. All right. All right. So another big part of this episode is Oscar baiting Michael into donating to his nephew's walkathon charity. But Michael sort of not getting nephew's walk-a-thon charity, but Michael sort of not getting what a walk-a-thon is, and so he puts in this big bid. And this is an example also of the benefit of the documentary crew element
《德克斯特：原罪》，新剧集12月13日上线。我们回来了。好吧。好吧。所以这一集的另一个重要部分是奥斯卡诱导迈克尔为他侄子的慈善步行活动捐款。但迈克尔有点没搞懂侄子的慈善步行活动是什么，所以他出了个大价钱。这也是纪录片摄制组元素的一个例子
of the show, because you can tell at first when Oscar walks into his office and asks him if he'll donate to his nephew's charity He doesn't want to he would if the cameras weren't there. He would probably say no, right, right But he can't say no look like a good guy He wants to look like a good guy. And so then he goes over the top and he donates $25 and only later is it brought to his attention that it's $25 per mile. Yes, exactly. And that realization happens in a great scene with Jim at the birthday party. And there
在剧中，因为你可以看出起初当奥斯卡走进他的办公室问他是否愿意为他侄子的慈善机构捐款时，他不想捐，如果摄像机不在那儿，他可能会说不，对吧，对吧。但他不能说不，看起来像个好人。他想看起来像个好人。所以他做得过火了，捐了25美元，直到后来才有人提醒他那是每英里25美元。是的，没错。那种领悟发生在一个与吉姆在生日派对上的精彩场景中。那里
is just this long pause. I'll tell you what, Steve Carell is better than anyone at letting an emotion wash across his face. And you watch that emotion of like, oh crap, like just like, oh, what'd I do? Like go across his face. And I feel like we see this again in Fun Run, right? Because he like signs up to do like so many miles and he doesn't realize. Something about Michael does not understand the concept of a walkathon. A walkathon or anything like that. But no, that is so good. What like something about Michael does not understand the concept of a walk-a-thon or
只是长久的停顿。我告诉你，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔比任何人都擅长让情绪在他的脸上流露。你看着那种情绪，就像，哦糟糕，就像，哦，我做了什么？流露在他的脸上。我觉得我们在《趣味跑》里又看到了这一点，对吧？因为他报名参加了那么多英里，但他没意识到。迈克尔有些地方就是不理解步行慈善活动的概念。步行慈善活动或类似的东西。但没有，那太好了。什么，迈克尔有些地方就是不理解步行慈善活动的概念或
anything like that. But no, that is so good. Well, I did. I added it up because in the in the episode, Michael, once he realizes it's per mile, he asks Oscar like, Hey, how strong is your nephew? Like, is he in good shape? Does he fit? So Michael has pledged $450. I did the math. He thinks he's pledged 25, but instead he pledged $450. I also need to go back. I skipped something that I think is really a fun thing. In the parking lot, there's a scene where Jim and Dwight, what am I going to say? It was Phyllis's car. It was Phyllis's car. Jim and Dwight are standing next to a car and they are comparing notes about everybody
类似的东西。但没有，那太好了。好吧，我做了。我加起来了，因为在这一集里，迈克尔一旦意识到是按英里计算，他问奥斯卡，嘿，你侄子身体强壮吗？他身体好吗？他合适吗？所以迈克尔承诺了450美元。我算了算。他以为他承诺了25美元，但实际上他承诺了450美元。我还需要回去。我跳过了一些我认为非常有趣的事情。在停车场，有一幕吉姆和德怀特，我要说什么？那是菲利斯的车。那是菲利斯的车。吉姆和德怀特站在一辆车旁边，他们正在比较关于每个人
in the office and what they've learned. And they're standing next to a car and it's Phyllis's car. Yes. And Rain, as Dwight, keeps kicking the car. Yeah. And Phyllis. She didn't care for it. She was very nervous about it.
在办公室里学到的东西。他们站在一辆车旁边，那是菲利斯的车。是的。雷恩，作为德怀特，一直在踢那辆车。是的。菲利斯。她不在乎。她对此非常紧张。
And I guess at some point she went up to Rain and said, listen, it's totally fine if you kick my car, but don't kick the car or the hubcap, just the tire. Just the tire. We used to park our cars in that little parking lot. Yeah. A lot of our real cars have appeared as cars in the show. And then they, in seasons later, they had us move our cars. I think maybe they realized there's like liability
我想在某个时候她走到雷恩面前说，听着，你踢我的车完全没问题，但别踢车身或轮毂盖，只踢轮胎。只踢轮胎。我们过去把车停在那个小停车场。是的。我们很多真实的车都作为剧中的车出现过。然后他们，在后来的几季里，让我们挪车。我想也许他们意识到有责任
or something. I mean, so, but in those early they had us move our cars. I think maybe they realized there's like liability or something. I mean, so, but in those early days, those were our cars. A very, very big element of this episode is the point where Dwight ends up in a box in the warehouse to spy. And more than any other question, when I put this out to fans for questions, the most questions that we got, the most frequently asked questions were about this box.
什么的。我是说，所以，但在那些早期他们让我们挪车。我想也许他们意识到有责任什么的。我是说，所以，在那些早期，那些是我们的车。这一集一个非常非常大的元素是德怀特最终为了监视而躲进仓库里的盒子里。比起任何其他问题，当我向粉丝征集问题时，我们收到的最多的问题，最常被问到的问题就是关于这个盒子。
How long was rain in the box? How many takes did we do? How many boxes did we use? One of the questions was, there's a scene where Pam is on the phone doing a fake phone call and the box kind of tips over. And I laugh and run off. Wait, I have a note card about this.
雷恩在盒子里待了多久？我们拍了多少条？我们用了多少个盒子？其中一个问题是，有一幕帕姆在打电话假装通话，盒子倒了。我笑了然后跑开了。等等，我有一张关于这个的笔记卡。
What is it? Okay, I know you put it out to Twitter, but this is your BFF. So I get to, can I ask you first? You get the first question. Jenna question, semi-pollin. Did you really break and laugh by the box? I think you did because I know what happens
是什么？好吧，我知道你把它发到了推特上，但这是你的闺蜜。所以我可以，我可以先问你吗？你得到第一个问题。珍娜问题，半民意调查。你真的笑场了吗？我想你肯定笑了，因为我知道当你真的笑的时候你的肩膀会发生什么。这就是那个问题。啊！这就是人们想知道的问题。我想我是装的。什么？是的，我不觉得我真的笑场了。我不想相信那个。我知道，我想，因为我记得拍摄那一幕
to your shoulders when you really laugh. This was the question. Ah! This is the question that people wanna know. I think I faked it. What? Yeah, I don't think I really broke. I don't wanna believe that. I know, I think, because I remember shooting that scene
我记得那非常技术性。好吧。所以它，它发生在。好吧。所以它，它发生在我肩膀上。事情发生在我肩膀上，但他们希望我在某个时刻笑场。所以这有点技术性。所以你得避开
and I remember it was very technical. Okay. So it was, it was happening over. Okay. So it was, it was happening over my shoulder. Stuff was happening on my shoulder, but there was a way where they wanted me to break at a certain moment. So it was kind of technical. So you had to sort of get out of the way
盒子在倾斜。是的，没错。所以我记得拍了很多次，我记得我心想，天哪，这看起来真实吗？就像我，我觉得演戏时有两件事真的很难。其中之一是哭，但我想人们会预料到这一点。
and the box was tipping. Yes, exactly. So I remember shooting it a number of times and I remember thinking to myself, gosh, does this even look real? Like do I, it's a really, there are two things that I think are really hard to do when you're acting. One of them is cry, but I think people would expect that.
但另一件是令人信服地笑。是的，你知道谁的假笑最好吗，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔能做出那种最诚实、最真诚的假笑。每次他做的时候，我都会开始笑。即使我知道那是假笑，那也是最诚实、最真诚的笑。每次他做的时候，我都会开始笑，即使我知道那是假笑。它太有感染力了。他是这方面最好的。我觉得自己哭比假笑容易。假笑非常困难。确实。我觉得我没有真的笑场的原因
But the other is to laugh convincingly. Yes, you know who has the best fake laugh is Steve Carell. Steve Carell can do this fake laugh that is the most honest, genuine laugh. And every time he would do it, I would start to laugh. Even though I knew it was a fake laugh that is the most honest, genuine laugh. And every time he would do it, I would start to laugh, even though I knew it was a fake laugh. It was so contagious. He is the best at it. I find it's easier to cry than to fake laugh myself. Fake laughing is very difficult. It is. The reason I think that I didn't really break
是因为我记得当时很焦虑，担心是否有人会相信。珍娜，我的笔记卡上有一点东西。是什么？我还有一张笔记卡，我写着这是我们第一次见到达里尔。是的，是的，当雷恩最后从盒子里跳出来时，达里尔就在下面。现在他不会有大场面，直到下一集《篮球》我们才会听到他说话。是的。但那是我们第一次见到达里尔。所以我很兴奋。我知道。看，我的笔记卡派上用场了。
is because I remember having anxiety over whether or not anyone was gonna buy it. Jenna I have a little something on my note card here. What is it? I have another note card I wrote this is the first time we see Darryl. Yes, yes when rain pops out of the box at the end Darryl is down there. Now he is not gonna have a big scene we're not to hear him speak until the next episode, which is basketball. Yes. But that is the first time we see Daryl. So I was very excited. I know. And look, my note card came in handy.
我喜欢她这一点。我喜欢我们如何埋下后来生长的种子。对。那是一个以后会成为剧中重要角色的人，但我们介绍他时只是一个看到雷恩从盒子里出来的家伙。是的，这是其中一件事，我知道我们一遍又一遍地说，我们在这个播客的整个生命周期里都会这么说，
I love that about her. I love how we plant seeds that grow later. Right. We don't, that is a person who is going to be a major character on the show, but we introduce him just as a guy seeing rain come out of the box. Yeah, that is one of the things, and I know we say it over and over, and we will for the life of this podcast,
但我喜欢格雷格·丹尼尔斯所做的一件事是，他从中间开始。他不喜欢喂你信息，只是他们设计节目的方式，作为观众你得赶上进度。你就像是生活中的一天，你就在中间。我喜欢那样。
but one of the things I love about what Greg Daniels did is he starts in the middle. He doesn't like spoon feed you information, just the way they designed the show, you play catch up as an audience member. You're just like a day in the life and you're right in the middle. And I love that.
是的，我也喜欢。好吧。关于盒子有个大秘密。这会让你大吃一惊。什么？雷恩大部分时间都不在盒子里。谁在盒子里？谁在盒子里？
Yes, I love that too. Okay. Here's a big confession about the box. This is gonna blow your mind. What? Rain wasn't in the box most of the time. Who was in the box? Who's in the box?
谁在盒子里？菲尔·谢伊，我们的道具师。道具师。是的。菲尔·谢伊。菲尔·谢伊是个很高的人。是的，雷恩也是。他一直都在那个盒子里。
Who was in the box? Phil Shea, our prop. Prop guy. Yeah. Phil Shea. Phil Shea is a very tall person. Yeah, well, so is Rain. And he was in that box all the time.
所以大部分盒子的表演都是菲尔·谢伊完成的，当然，除了最后雷恩冲出来的那部分。然后回来。所以在那个我笑喷的场景里，菲尔·谢伊在盒子里。哦天哪。你知道我觉得我们该做什么吗，安吉拉？告诉我，珍娜。我觉得我们是的。菲尔·谢伊在盒子里。哦天哪。你知道我觉得我们该做什么吗，安吉拉？告诉我，珍娜。
So most of the box acting was done by Phil Shea, of course, except for the end where Rain busts out. And comes back. So in that scene where I'm cracking up, Phil Shea was in the box. Oh my gosh. You know what I think we should do, Angela? Tell me, Jenna. I think we Yes. Phil Shea was in the box. Oh my gosh. You know what I think we should do, Angela? Tell me, Jenna.
我觉得我们应该给菲尔·谢伊打电话，让他回答我们关于盒子的所有问题。我们做吧。在盒子里是什么感觉？菲尔·谢伊，我们要打爆你的电话了。喂？菲尔？是的。
I think we should call Phil Shea and get him to answer all of our questions about the box. Let's do it. What was it like in the box? Phil Shea, we are about to blow up your phone. Hello? Phil? Yes.
菲尔·谢伊，我是珍娜和安吉拉。嗨，菲尔。哦，嘿，伙计们，你们好吗？好，你呢？非常感谢你让我们打电话来打扰你。能帮到帕姆和安吉拉总是我的荣幸。哦天哪。菲尔，非常感谢。
Phil Shea, it's Jenna and Angela. Hi, Phil. Oh, hey guys, how are you? Good, how are you? Thank you so much for letting us call and bug you. It's always a pleasure to help out Pam and Angela. Oh my gosh. Phil, thank you so much.
不得不说，听到你的声音真好。我也是这么想的。我心想，天哪，听到你的声音真好。嘿，我们九年来的经历，对吧？是的，我们是最幸运的。我们是最幸运的。好吧，如果你有时间，菲尔，我们可以问你一些关于《结盟》那一集的问题吗？当然。
It's just so nice to hear your voice, I have to say. That's what I was thinking. I was like, gosh, it's so nice to hear your voice. Hey, what an experience we had for nine years, right? Yes, we were the luckiest. We were the luckiest. Well, if you have a second, Phil, can we ask you some questions from the Alliance episode? Absolutely.
所以，我们向粉丝征集了问题，人们最想知道的压倒性问题是关于雷恩在仓库里钻进去的那个盒子。哦天哪。他们想知道他在盒子里待了多久，关于盒子的所有事，但菲尔，我知道你在盒子里。雷恩是在所有的推搡、挤压、笨拙和翻滚完成后才进去的。是的。
So, we opened up questions to the fans and overwhelmingly the thing people wanted to know about was the box that Rain gets into in the warehouse. Oh my gosh. They wanted to know how long he was in the box, everything about the box, but Phil, I know you were in the box. Rain only got in after all the shooing and the scooching and the plodding and then the tumbling was done. Yeah.
菲尔，你在盒子里做了所有那些动作。你是那个挤压者、翻滚者和所有那些动作的人。我是。显然，我们的制片主任兹博纳克先生认为我们没有足够的钱雇特技演员。所以他指派我进盒子。我记得我不得不出去买我自己的护肘和护膝。然后我带了一个松动的对讲机进去，和莉兹·瑞恩在一起，她是第一助理制片，
Phil, you did all of that in the box. You were the scoocher and the tumbler and all that. I was. Apparently Mr. Zbornak, our line producer, didn't think we had enough money to hire a stunt guy. So he assigned me to be in the box. And I remember I had to go out and buy my own elbow pads and knee pads. And then I had a loose walkie talkie in there with me with Liz Ryan, who was the first AP,
大声喊出布莱恩·戈登，也就是我们那一集的导演的指令。我记得就像昨天一样。所以菲尔，你能从头给我讲讲吗？你拿到剧本，上面写着，这个角色必须在一个盒子里。那你做什么？因为你负责弄到盒子
shouting out all of Brian Gordon, who was our director for that episode's command. I remember like it was yesterday. So Phil, can you take me through it from the beginning? You get a script and it says, this character has to be in a box. So what do you do? Cause you're in charge of getting the box
作为道具师。所以你从哪里开始？关于那个特定的道具，我只是，我去找了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，我说，你看到雷恩坐在盒子里蹲着，还是他跪在地上手脚着地？他说跪在手上。雷恩很高，雷恩很高，对吧？
as the prop master. So where do you start? On that particular prop, I just, I saw out Greg Daniels and I said, do you see Rain sitting down squatting in the box or does he kneeling down on his hands and knees and he said kneeling on his hands. And Rain is tall, Rain is tall, right?
你也是，菲尔，你很高。是的，雷恩我想有6英尺1或6英尺2，如果我吹干头发我有6英尺1。你的头发确实很棒。就像你们应该知道的，菲尔有一头很棒的头发。他确实有。这是真的。我租的。
And so are you Phil, you're very tall. Yeah, Rain is I think 6'1 or 6'2, I'm 6'1 if I blow dry my hair. You do have great hair. Like you guys should know, Phil has an amazing head of hair. He really does. This is true. I least it.
我租的。这是好莱坞的假发型。但我找到了雷恩，我让他手脚着地，我是这个盒子的设计师。等等，你让雷恩手脚着地，然后你测量了他？你测量了他以知道多大。那是第一季，雷恩愿意做任何事。
I least it. It's a Hollywood fake hairdo. But I tracked Rain down, and I asked him to get on his hands and knees, and I was a designer for this box. Wait, you made Rain get on his hands and knees, and then you measured him? And you measured him to know how big a. That was season one, Rain was willing to do anything.
然后我去了南加州的一些盒子城，没人有接近那个尺寸的盒子。所以我上了互联网，查了南加州的盒子制造商。我在圣地亚哥找到了一家叫肯特·兰斯伯格的公司，你必须明白，作为道具人员，我们制作和获得所有这些道具的时间和提前期非常短，所以我给这家肯特·兰斯伯格纸业公司打了电话
Then I went to a couple box cities around Southern California, no one had a box close to that. So then I went onto the internet and I looked at box manufacturers in Southern California. I found a company in San Diego named Kent Landsberg and you have to understand as prop people we have a very short production time and lead time to get all these props so I called this Kent Landsberg paper
公司，要求和经理通话，我用一种更狂热、更亢奋的声音说，听着，你得帮帮我，我得做一个定制盒子，我可能需要大约一百个，而且它们需要是这个尺寸。圣地亚哥也离这儿有三个小时路程。好吧，而且，那是个很好的观点。你不需要一个盒子。你需要100个盒子，因为你不知道我们要拍多少条。
company and asked to speak to the manager and in a much more frenetic and hyper voice I said look you got to help me out I have to have a custom box made I probably need about a hundred of, and they need to be the dimension. And San Diego's like three hours away, too. Well, and also, that's such a good point. You didn't need one box. You needed 100 boxes, because you didn't know how many takes we were going to do.
而这一集的导演布莱恩·戈登以拍很多条而闻名。所以你覆盖你的基础并获得一百个是正确的。是的。对。我们在邓德·米夫林的仓库里拍了那一幕。我们想在架子上放一些盒子，就是这样。哦，对。
And Brian Gordon, the director of this episode, ended up being notorious for doing tons of takes. So you were right to cover your bases and get a hundred. Yes. Right. And we shot that scene in the Dunder Mifflin warehouse. We wanted to have some boxes on the shelves and that was it. Oh, right.
只是他没冲出来的那些。是的，当然。对。那不是道具盒。它只是凭空出现的。所以我们必须给它的来源一些合法性。看看所有的细节。看看所有的细节。所以你是怎么做的？这家伙说他没问题，然后你是怎么弄到它们的？好吧，我和他谈过，他说提前期通常是
Just ones that he didn't bust out of. Yeah, of course. Right. It wasn't a prop box. It just appeared out of nowhere. So we had to give some legitimacy to where it originated from. Look at all the detail. Look at all the details. So how did you do it? This guy said he would do it no problem and then how'd you get them? Well I talked to him he said the lead time is usually
一个半月。我说我们有四天。我说我需要在四天内拿到盒子，我说这是为了一部电视剧。他说这是《办公室》，是英国版的翻拍。他可能说我很抱歉，我是英国版的超级粉丝，我不是为了一部电视剧。他说这是《办公室》，是英国版的翻拍。他可能说，我很抱歉，我是英国版的超级粉丝，我对帮你没兴趣。我从来没听说过你们的节目。就像你们在偷听电话一样，他就是这么说的。
a month and a half. I said we have four days. I said I need the boxes in four days and I said it was for a tv show. He said it's for the office which is a remake of the British version. And he probably said I'm sorry I'm a huge fan of the British version and I'm not was for a TV show. He said it's for The Office, which is a remake of the British version. And he probably said, I'm sorry, I'm a huge fan of the British version and I'm not interested in helping you. I had never heard of your show. It's like you guys were listening into the phone call, that's exactly what he said.
不，他说他很乐意为一部电视剧破例。所以他做到了。我们把盒子运到了卡尔弗城，那是我们第一季拍摄那一集的地方。然后他们把图形贴在盒子上，我们在拍摄前两天拿到了它们。所以我们都做完了，雷恩在盒子里很合适。
No, he said he would be glad to make an exception for a TV show. So he made it happen. We got the boxes delivered to Culver City, which is where we shot that episode in our first season. And then they put the graphics on the box and we had them back two days before we were filming. So we had it all done and rain fit in the box fine.
然后就是协调我进去时用德怀特的瑞士军刀插入孔洞的位置。那是个很棒的场景。我是说，我记得我们拍了那个。我想那是周五晚上我们拍的，但很有趣。每个人都在笑。剧组总是我们拍了那个。我想那是周五晚上我们拍的，但，很有趣。每个人都在笑。
And then it was just about coordinating where the holes would be inserted by me when I'm inside the box with Dwight's Swiss Army knife. And it was a great scene. I mean, I remember we shot that down. I think it was a Friday night we shot that scene, but it was fun. Everybody was laughing. The crew was always we shot that down. I think it was a Friday night we shot that scene, but it was, it was fun. Everybody was laughing.
剧组在那部剧里总是笑个不停，呃，那是个很棒的站立目标，粉丝们非常喜欢它。哦，菲尔，非常感谢。我，我正在看一张我可以发邮件给你的照片，是迈克尔·加伦伯格给我的。我们挂断电话后，我会立刻发给你一张我准备用胶带封住第一个盒子的照片。我不知道你有没有那个播客上的照片，但我会拍张照片。也许我们可以把它放在我们的网站上。是的。是的。好吧，我会拍张照片，你可以看到我脸上的表情，在
The crew was always laughing on that show and, uh, it was a great standing goal and fans love it so much. Oh, Phil, thank you so much. I have, I'm looking at a picture that I can email you that Michael Gallenberg gave me. I'm going to send you a picture as soon as we hang up of me getting ready to tape up a fist box. And I don't know if you have the Oh my gosh. the picture on the podcast but I'm gonna take a picture. We can put it on our website maybe. Yeah. Yeah. Okay I'll take a picture and you can see by the expression on my face after
大约第50条之后。你就像在汗蒸房里一样。哦菲尔，谢谢。但珍娜，你在那儿，你记得最后一条当布莱恩·戈登说再来一条时，我希望你记得这个，他让我做所有这些事，然后当我把自己从盒子里切出来时，每个人都躲起来了。哦，没错。我出来到了仓库，所以他至少在最后对我开了个恶作剧让我笑，所以那挺有趣的。我们做到了。我们把你留在盒子里，我们假装我们还在拍摄，然后你就待了那么久。那太可怕了。
about take 50. You were like in a sweat lodge. Oh Phil, thank you. But Jenna, you were there, and you remember the last take when Brian Gordon said one more, I hope you remember this, where he had me do all this stuff, and then when I cut myself out of the box, everybody had went and hit. Oh, and that's right. I came out into the warehouse, so he at least played a practical joke on me at the end to make me laugh, so that was pretty funny. We did. We left you in the box, and we pretended like we were were still filming and then you just were there for so long. That is horrible.
我们为什么那么刻薄？菲尔，如果我在那儿，菲尔，我会走过去说，菲尔出来吧。他们走了。那太搞笑了。不，那非常有趣。那是个很棒的场景。菲尔，我确实。我能在放你走之前快速问你两个问题吗？再问两个？哦，好吧。好吧，在拿到这个盒子之后，听起来这是一项巨大的工程。菲尔，你的工作听起来真的很有趣。
Why were we so mean? Phil, I would have if I was there Phil, I would have come up and said, Phil get out. They left. It was so funny. No, it was very funny. It was a great scene. Phil, I do. Can I throw two questions at you really quickly before we let you go? Two more? Oh, okay. Okay, so after getting this box, sounds like it was a massive undertaking. Phil, your job is sounding really fun.
就像你读了一集，然后你必须想出所有这些奇怪的物体和噱头。听起来既有趣又有压力，菲尔。你是怎么在四天内弄到100个盒子的？总是很有趣。总是很有压力。能像我说的那样，成为一部与观众产生共鸣的制作的一小部分真是太好了
Like you read an episode and then you have to come up with all these weird objects and gags. It sounds fun and stressful, Phil. Like how do you get 100 boxes in four days? It's always fun. It's always stressful. And it's great to be, like I said, a small part of a production that resonates with viewers
和跨代粉丝，就像《办公室》那样。所以它很有趣。它很有压力。但做这件事真是种快乐。当每个人都笑，每个人都喜欢这个道具，它给剧本场景增加了一点价值，然后我们都回家笑，度过美好的一天。所以是的，我们喜欢它。
and fans across generations as The Office did. So it is fun. It is stressful. But it's a real joy to do it. When everybody laughs and everybody enjoys the prop and it adds a little value to the scripted scene and then we all go home and laugh and have a good day. So yeah, we love it.
好吧，我们确实很感激你，我们会经常给你打电话的，办公室女士们。所以谢谢。谢谢你花时间，菲尔。我对我们为《办公室》制作的所有道具都有生动的记忆，所以任何时候你们想给我打电话，了解幕后花絮。我们可以吗？好吧，因为当你说话时，
Well, we sure appreciate you and we are gonna be calling you a lot, the office ladies. So thank you. Thanks for taking the time, Phil. I have vivid memories of all the props we made for the office, so anytime you guys wanna call me, get behind the scenes. Can we? Okay, because as you were talking,
我脑子里有八个关于以后不同剧集的问题。所以，我也有。我们一定会再给你打电话的，菲尔。非常感谢。我们想念你。是的，让我们保持邓德·米夫林的活力。我也想念你们。让我们让邓德·米夫林在未来30年里保持相关性。
I had like eight questions about different episodes down the road. So, I did too. We will definitely be calling you back, Phil. Thank you so much. We miss you. Yeah, let's keep Dunder Mifflin going. I miss you as well. Let's keep Dunder Mifflin relevant for the next 30 years.
我喜欢。耶！好吧，菲尔。好吧，祝你今天愉快。是的，告诉大家我们向那边问好。好吧。我会的。谢谢，安吉拉。再见。
I love it. Yay! All right, Phil. Well, have a good day. Yeah, tell everyone we say hi over there. Okay. I will. Thanks, Angela. Bye.
再见。谢谢，再见。接下来是什么，珍娜？我还有三张笔记卡。好吧，现在我们需要谈谈蛋糕。哦，是的。冰淇淋，薄荷巧克力碎冰淇淋蛋糕。是的。我病得太厉害了。巧克力碎冰淇淋蛋糕。是的。
Bye. Thank you, bye. What's next, Jenna? I have three note cards left. Well, now we need to talk about the cake. Oh, yes. The ice cream, the mint chocolate chip ice cream cake. Yes. I got so sick. We chocolate chip ice cream cake. Yes.
我病得太厉害了。我们吃了那个蛋糕。这是第二个最常被问到的问题，是关于蛋糕的，蛋糕是什么样的，我们真的吃了那个蛋糕吗？哦，我们吃了那个蛋糕，伙计们。你猜怎么着？你开始拍摄，我们会在早上7点30分开始拍摄。
I got so sick. We ate that cake. This is the second most frequently asked question was about the cake and what the cake was like and did we really eat the cake? Oh, we ate that cake, you guys. And guess what? You start filming, we would start filming at 7.30 AM.
所以早上7点30分，你要吃冰淇淋蛋糕？有人在早上7点30分给你一盘冰淇淋蛋糕。你要吃冰淇淋蛋糕？有人递给你一盘冰淇淋蛋糕，在早上7点30分。你要吃它五个小时？一整天。一整天。然后他们说，休息一下吃午饭。你说，我想吐。是的。让我说点关于道具食物的事。
So at 7.30 AM, you're gonna eat ice cream cake? Someone had you a plate of ice cream cake at 7.30 AM. And you're gonna eat ice cream cake? Someone hands you a plate of ice cream cake at 730 a.m. And you're gonna eat it for five hours? All day. All day. And then they're like, let's break for lunch. And you're like, I wanna puke. Yeah. Let me say something about prop food.
哦，说吧。BJ·诺瓦克喜欢道具食物。敏迪·卡灵喜欢道具食物。我也挺喜欢的。当我在场景里必须吃零食时，我会很兴奋。我不喜欢，因为我知道它会让我难受。我知道，它每次都让我难受，但我还是犯同样的错误。每次。我会看到艾德·赫尔姆斯、敏迪·卡灵、你、BJ会像，
Oh, do it. BJ Novak loves prop food. Mindy Kaling loves prop food. I also kinda like it. I get real excited when I have to snack in a scene. I do not because I know it's gonna turn on me. I know and it turns on me every time and I still make the same mistakes. Every time. I would see Ed Helms, Minnie Kaling, you, BJ be like,
哦，道具食物，变得很兴奋，说，伙计们，控制一下。这会变得很恶心。我们在会议室开派对，他们会有像猪肉卷之类的东西，你只是，我和BJ会在那边。我会说伙计们慢点。我知道。你得吃那个四个小时。我知道。好吧，这是我第一次犯错，我开始早早地狼吞虎咽冰淇淋蛋糕。然后你必须在每个镜头里匹配它。所以你在第一个镜头里做的任何事，你都必须匹配它。所以从连续性上来说，这一切都说得通。
ooh, brought food and get so excited and be like, guys, pace yourself. It's gonna get gross. We'd have a party in the conference room and they'd have like pigs in a blanket and you just, me and BJ would be over there. I'd be like guys slow down. I know. You're gonna have to eat that for four hours. I know. Well this was the first time that I made the mistake and I started wolfing down ice cream cake early. And then you have to match that in every shot. So whatever you do in that first shot you then have to match it. So continuity wise, it all makes sense.
事情是这样的，我在大多数吃冰淇淋场景的背景里。你在想什么？所以我当时在背景里狼吞虎咽。她不必，她在背景里。我在背景里。然后当我该拍特写时，我病得太厉害了。
And here's the thing, I'm in the background of most of the ice cream eating scenes. What are you thinking? So I was wolfing it down in the background. She didn't have to, she was in the background. I was in the background. And then by the time it was time for my closeup, I was so sick.
我不想吃冰淇淋蛋糕，但后来我不得不吃。我告诉你，我病得太厉害了。我不想吃冰淇淋蛋糕，但后来我不得不吃。妮可·苏尔——我告诉你。我吃了一片，迈克尔走到菲利斯和我身边，当他走过来时，可怜的史蒂夫在说话时狼吞虎咽地吃着蛋糕。妮可·苏尔——他每一条都会吃掉整整一块。妮可·苏尔——哦天哪，他们最终弄了个桶，他可以吐出来。妮可·苏尔——这也令人作呕。妮可·苏尔——这叫吐桶。
I didn't wanna eat the ice cream cake, but then I had to. I'll tell you this, I was so sick. I didn't want to eat the ice cream cake, but then I had to. Nicole Soule-I'll tell you this. I had a slice and Michael walks up to Phyllis and I, and when he walks up, poor Steve is like wolfing the cake down as he's talking. Nicole Soule-He would eat a full piece every take. Nicole Soule-Oh man, they eventually got a bucket though that he could spit. Nicole Soule-Which is also disgusting. Nicole Soule-It's called a spit bucket.
我本来不想吃冰淇淋蛋糕，但后来不得不吃。我跟你说，我当时难受极了。我本来不想吃冰淇淋蛋糕，但后来不得不吃。Nicole Soule-我跟你说。我吃了一块，然后迈克尔走到我和菲利斯面前，当他走过来时，可怜的史蒂夫一边说话一边狼吞虎咽地吃着蛋糕。Nicole Soule-他每一条拍摄都要吃掉整整一块。Nicole Soule-天哪，他们最后还是拿来了一个桶让他吐掉。Nicole Soule-这也挺恶心的。Nicole Soule-那叫吐痰桶。
Nicole Soule-It's called a spit bucket. It's called a spit bucket. But he would walk up eating the cake and he was talking to Phyllis and Meredith and my character and I was just going to take one bite as he walked up. And by the end of the five hours of doing the scene, when I would scoop up that one bite my hand would start to shake because I was anticipating it. So I was like, oh, yes, your body was rejecting. My body was rejecting it. It was like, please don't put that mint chocolate
Nicole Soule-这叫吐痰桶。这叫吐痰桶。但他走过来吃蛋糕时，正在和Phyllis、Meredith还有我的角色说话，我本来打算在他走过来时只咬一口。在拍了五个小时这场戏后，当我舀起那一口时，我的手开始发抖，因为我在预料着那一刻。所以我当时想，哦，是的，你的身体在排斥。我的身体在排斥它。它就像在说，求你别再把那薄荷巧克力
chip ice cream in your mouth one more time ever again for the rest of your life. I can't eat it. I can't eat it. I can't eat it now. My daughter loves mint chocolate chip. I don't want it near me. I loved ice cream cake in general.
碎冰淇淋放进嘴里了，这辈子都别再吃了。我吃不下。我吃不下。我现在吃不下。我女儿喜欢薄荷巧克力碎。我不想让它靠近我。我总体上是很喜欢冰淇淋蛋糕的。
No. And only it was last year for my son's seventh birthday, I finally ate a piece of ice cream cake again. But that's, it had been like, I'd gone on like a 15 year moratorium. So the final thing I think we should talk about with this episode. Oh yeah, let's go on that note. Is the scene with Roy coming into the office
不。直到去年我儿子七岁生日时，我才终于又吃了一块冰淇淋蛋糕。但那是因为，我已经有大约15年没碰过它了。所以，我觉得我们应该讨论一下这一集的最后一件事。哦，是的，就聊聊那个吧。就是Roy来到办公室
and confronting Jim. You guys are so busted. I remember like being over in accounting being like, oh, and also David Denman can be scary when he wants to be. He can be intimidating. He's such a teddy bear in real life. I know, but when he came in like that, I was like, he's a big guy. And I think he turns my character on because he's such a man. Like, you see that play out later where I'm like, I'm clearly, like, enamored with Roy. But in that moment, I was like, oh my god, Roy is going to kick Jim's ass.
并与Jim对峙的那场戏。你们俩被抓个正着。我记得当时在会计部，心想，哦，而且David Denman想吓人的时候真的很吓人。他很有威慑力。他在现实生活中是个大暖男。我知道，但当他那样走进来时，我心想，他是个大块头。而且我觉得他激起了我角色的兴趣，因为他很有男人味。就像你后来看到的那样，我显然是被Roy迷住了。但在那一刻，我心想，天哪，Roy要揍Jim了。
Yeah, your character Angela likes a beefy alpha male, for sure. She just does. That's true. So I remember this scene. I remember breaking it down. We shot a ton of versions of this scene because we really didn't know how big of a reaction
是的，你的角色Angela确实喜欢那种强壮的阿尔法男性。她就是喜欢。没错。所以我记得这场戏。我记得我们拆解了这场戏。我们拍了无数个版本，因为我们真的不知道Roy的反应
Roy should have. So the first thing I remember was that somehow in the scene, when Jim and I are giggling about our accomplishment, we had to find a way to hold hands. That there had to be like- An organic way. An organic way where his arm is around me. There had to be something,
应该有多大。所以我记得的第一件事是，不知怎么的，在这一幕中，当Jim和我为我们的成就窃窃私语时，我们必须找到一种方式来牵手。必须有一种——一种自然的方式。一种自然的方式，让他的手臂搂着我。必须得有某种动作，
because Roy has walked in the door before and seen Jim standing at reception talking to me. So we had to come up with this reason that John would come around the front of the desk. He's so excited. Yeah, he's so excited that he jogs around. So instead of coming up to me with the desk between us, which is what you've seen in the past, this was a big moment. He breaks that barrier.
因为Roy之前走进门时看到过Jim站在前台和我说话。所以我们必须想出一个理由，让John绕到桌子前面。他太兴奋了。是的，他太兴奋了，所以他小跑着绕了过来。所以，不像过去那样隔着桌子和我说话，这是一个重要的时刻。他打破了那道屏障。
He comes around the desk. He puts his arm on me. We end up kind of holding hands and giggling. And I remember us really struggling to make sure that it looked real and organic and not staged. We didn't want to do something so out of the ordinary that you would be expecting something to happen. Right.
他绕过桌子。他把手臂搭在我身上。我们最终牵着手窃窃私语。我记得我们真的很努力地确保它看起来真实自然，而不是刻意安排的。我们不想做得太反常，以至于让你预料到会发生什么。没错。
And I think we accomplished it. And then when he burst in the door, there were a couple of takes where he pushed Jim up against a wall, where he got really more physical with Jim. And so we shot all these different versions so that we could get it just right. Right. And the version they went with is the best. I think if Roy had gotten too physical there, it just would have taken us all out of it. Cause we'd be like, whoa. But I think just how ticked off he was. And then I thought John was brilliant in that moment.
我想我们做到了。当他冲进门时，有几个镜头是他把Jim推到墙上，他与Jim有了更多的肢体接触。所以我们拍了所有这些不同的版本，以便能达到最好的效果。没错。他们最终选用的那个版本是最好的。我想如果Roy当时表现得太暴力，反而会让我们出戏。因为我们会觉得，哇。但我认为他当时表现出的愤怒程度刚刚好。而且我觉得John在那一刻的表现非常精彩。
He was so believable when he was like, I don't even know how to explain this. Cause he realizes how ridiculous their whole day has been. And how do you explain what they've been doing? Yeah. And they're so busted though. I know. It is a moment that made me totally cringe.
他当时的样子太令人信服了，他说他甚至不知道该怎么解释。因为他意识到他们这一整天过得有多荒唐。你怎么解释他们一直在做的事情？是的。但他们确实被抓个正着。我知道。那一刻让我完全尴尬得蜷缩起来。
Yeah, and you know that Pam and Roy had words about that. Oh, the car ride home. The car. Yes, yes, car ride home. That was a tough one. My husband and I always talk about that. It will be at a dinner party or something, and you see a couple have like an awkward exchange, I'll like lean over to my husband and be like, oh, car ride home, car ride homes. That's kind of be a rough one.
是的，你知道Pam和Roy为此吵过架。哦，回家的车上。车上。是的，是的，回家的车上。那是一次艰难的谈话。我和我丈夫总是谈论这个。在晚宴或其他场合，如果你看到一对夫妇有尴尬的交流，我会凑到我丈夫耳边说，哦，回家的车上，回家的车上。那肯定会是一场艰难的谈话。
So that's it. That's the Alliance. Can I say one more thing? I want to say one more thing. This episode has a special place in my family's life. Why? Because while we were shooting this episode, they got me out early so that I could go home for my sister's wedding. My real sister's wedding, I had to travel. So she got married while we were shooting this episode and this year she celebrated her 15th wedding anniversary. Aww.
所以就是这样。这就是《联盟》那一集。我能再说一件事吗？我想再说一件事。这一集在我家人的生活中占有特殊的地位。为什么？因为在拍摄这一集时，他们让我提前离开，这样我就可以回家参加我姐姐的婚礼。我亲姐姐的婚礼，我必须去旅行。所以她在我们拍摄这一集时结婚了，今年她庆祝了结婚15周年。噢。
Isn't that sweet? So when I was watching this, I remembered that. That's like a fun full circle life moment too. I know. Well, this is the thing you guys are going to hear a lot as we do this podcast is, you know, this show spanned 10 years of our lives and so much life happens in those 10 years. And we really do have all these special memories of our own lives mixed in with what was happening on The Office. And I feel like it shows because we all became
这不是很甜蜜吗？所以当我看到这一集时，我想起了这件事。这就像是一个有趣的生命轮回时刻。我知道。好吧，这就是你们在听这个播客时会经常听到的，你知道，这部剧跨越了我们生活的10年，在这10年里发生了太多的事情。我们确实有所有这些特殊的个人生活记忆，与《办公室》里发生的事情交织在一起。我觉得这表现出来了，因为我们大家都变得
so invested in each other's lives. We are our own misfit family. Like the cast of The Office, the people that played the characters on The Office in real life have a lot of shared life moments and memories. And I think it just makes the show special to me. So when I watch it, I remember things too. Yeah.
如此投入彼此的生活。我们就像一个古怪的家庭。就像《办公室》的演员阵容一样，在现实生活中扮演《办公室》角色的这些人有很多共同的生活时刻和记忆。我认为这让这部剧对我来说很特别。所以当我观看它时，我也想起了这些事情。是的。
And it's just so, I love that you shared that. Yay. OK, that was the alliance, everyone. That's right. Don't judge me for the bobblehead moment. Don't judge me. Jenna's already judging me enough. So just, you know, you can rest. I judged you, and then it was over,
而且我真的很喜欢你分享这些。耶。好了，这就是《联盟》，大家。没错。别因为那个摇头娃娃的时刻评判我。别评判我。Jenna已经够评判我的了。所以，你知道，你可以放心了。我评判过你，然后就结束了，
because then you pointed out that great other fact about your outfit. Thank you very much. You earned back my respect immediately. OK, next week is basketball. Basketball, one of my favorites. When we became best friends. We became best friends.
因为后来你指出了关于你服装的那个很棒的事实。非常感谢。你立刻赢回了我的尊重。好了，下周是《篮球》。篮球，我的最爱之一。我们成为好朋友的时候。我们成为了好朋友。
And basketball. While shooting the basketball episode, we're gonna tell you all about it. We'll tell you all about it. All right, see ya. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created
还有篮球。在拍摄篮球那一集时，我们会告诉你们所有关于它的事。我们会告诉你们的。好了，再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是
in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jerkins，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是Daniella Silva。Odyssey的执行制片人是Jenna Weis-Berman和Leah Reese Dennis。《办公室女士》由Chris Basil混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。